et féministe facilement il y à un
discrédit de principes posés sur le mot
féministe alors que c'est simplement la
reconnaissance de son existence d'être
faits mineurs est ce que vous diriez
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un an tu reçois
masculin dans l'église
bien sûr qu'il y à nantes reçoit metz
que la chine est un plafond de verre qui
empêche les femmes d'être pleinement
reconnus dans leur propre église
elles ne sont jamais autonomes dans leur
dans leur prise de décision
elles ne sont pas reconnues comme des
citoyennes à part entière donc il est
temps il est temps de dire que l'église
ne peut pas fonctionner sur un seul de
ses poumons
elle ne peut pas marcher sur une seule
de ses jambes
l'église doit être faite d'hommes et de
femmes et il est temps que ça change
[Musique]
où
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble pour
deux heures d'émission la première de
cette rentrée j'ai le plaisir de vous
retrouver nous décrypterons chaque soir
du lundi au jeudi l'essentiel de
l'information avec un nos invités et nos
reporters sur le terrain voici les
grands titres de l'actualité de ce mardi
8 septembre la présidence du groupe la
république en marge dans la tête de tous
les marcheurs les cinq candidats ont
débattu avec les députés macro nist
l'occasion d'appeler au rassemblement
alors que le groupe doit encore ses
rangs se réduire avec des démarches des
alliés du modem pour décrypter cette
rentrée et ses enjeux nous serons dans
quelques instants avec eux alexis
poulain dans notre nouvelle rubrique est
dit tout dans un contexte marqué par la
sphère navel ni la france et des états
unis ont émis des réserves quant à la
construction du gazoduc censé relier la
russie à l'allemagne berlin n'exclut
désormais plus de retirer son soutien à
un art stream 2 sauf si moscou clarifie
ce qui s'est passé concernant l'opposant
russe est la russie déplore la
politisation du dossier
[Musique]
si le bélarus tombe la prochaine sera la
russie déclarations d'alexandre
loukachenko alors que la capitale de la
biélorussie est à nouveau le centre
d'affrontements entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre
barry réagi ce soir et condamnent je
suis que les arrestations arbitraires et
l'exil forcé d'opposants le break site
londres reconnaît que la révision prévue
de l'accord viole le droit international
c'est pourtant ce qu'ont visage boris
johnson si aucune entente n'est trouvée
le dernier round de négociations reprend
dans un contexte de tension très vive
entre les deux camps bruxelles reste
ferme il n'y aura pas de retour sur les
engagements pris le node il plane
toujours
[Musique]
et cette lourde perte donc pour le parti
des manuels mettront une dizaine de
députés la république en mars s'apprête
à rejoindre le modem à l'assemblée
nationale le parti de françois bayrou se
trouvera fortement renforcée au
palais-bourbon passant de 47 à 63
députés
le groupe ma chronique n'avait déjà
perdu la majorité en mai dernier il
devra plus que jamais composer avec son
allié centriste tandis que le prochain
chef de file de la république en marge
doit être élu cette semaine
aurore bergé espère bien l'emporter face
à l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner ont fait le coin
tout de suite avec notre reporter katia
technique à l'assemblée c'est la
dernière ligne droite de la bataille
pour élire le nouveau président du
groupe
lrm à l'assemblée les députés vont voter
aujourd'hui
le second tour aura lieu demain matin et
les résultats seront proclamés jeudi
après midi
c'est la troisième élection en trois ans
pour le groupe cette dernière fait suite
à la démission de gilles legendre en
juillet alors cinq candidats sont en
lice
et parmi eux deux font la course en tête
christophe castaner et aurore bergé
les autres candidats sont françois de
rugy actuellement député de
loire-atlantique coralie dubost député
de l'hérault ainsi que patrice anatole
député de seine saint denis que propose
tirait bien christophe castaner souhaite
pousser trois textes d'initiative
parlementaire
l'aide publique au développement le
bien-être animal et la fin de vie
aurore bergé quand elle souhaite se
concentrer sur l' app sur la protection
de l'enfance et la lutte contre la
pauvreté devront mobiliser
un groupe qui est fragilisée parfois
désabusés christophe castaner est perçu
comme l'homme qui suivra la ligne
élyséenne
mais qui ne changera pas en profondeur
les choses mais qui peut permettre au
groupe de mieux fonctionner quant à
aurore bergé
elle est perçue comme une personne plus
dirigiste qui pourrait même provoquer
des scissions au sein du groupe et c'est
un moment assez fatidique pour lrm car
dix députés souhaitent souhaite quitter
le groupe tout simplement selon les
informations du point
alors une nouvelle qui n'a pas manqué de
faire réagir de députés de l'opposition
se propose de les écouter
une façon de traduire un certain
mécontentement voilà peut-être aussi
qu'on en a certains qui s'inquiètent de
réflexion sur l'éthique est en marche
à l'avenir parce qu'elle sera peut-être
pas forcément très très glorieuse de
tissa qui se pose comme question
moi j'avais pensez qu'ils auraient
abandonné une débandade importante parce
que les marcheurs sont sont rôle de
majorité il ya des gens qui avaient des
qui doivent s'interroger par exemple sur
le retour à une vie professionnelle qui
parfois été plus rentable entre
guillemets si on regarde ça en politique
c'est pas mon cas que la fonction de
député d'autres qui commence
effectivement à se demander comment
garder le poste de député dans dans le
cadre d'une majorité qui qui à mon avis
va donc fond des problèmes aux
départementales régionales et puis
présidentielle vous savez ce groupe de
députés la république en marche
il en est je crois sans 35e départ
depuis le début du mandat ce groupe est
en train de s'étioler
les députés partent les uns après les
autres a pas une semaine sans que nous
annonce le départ d'un député de la
majorité pour une simple et bonne raison
y a pas de cohérence dans ce groupe
parce qu'il n'y a pas de défense d'idées
en fait ces gens là ont été élus non pas
pour défendre des idées mais pour
défendre des intérêts et lorsqu'il
considère que les intérêts qu'ils
défendent ne sont pas bien représentés
ils s'en vont en fait ces gens là ne
défendent pas la france c'est la
superposition l'amoncellement de
défenseurs d'intérêts divers et variés y
aucune unité d'ensemble aucune vision
d'ensemble
c'est en fait le le bout la fin du en
même temps sur les dix députés censés
quitter le groupe euler hermes trois
d'entre eux ont déjà officialisé leur
départ il s'agit de blandine brocard du
rhône de perrine goulet de la nièvre et
de patrick blanchet du calvados d'autres
députés l air
mme avait déjà quitté le groupe en août
et en outre des parlementaires d'autres
partis s'apprête à rejoindre également
les centristes ont tout cela est le
fruit des ambitions de patrick mignola
le chef du groupe du modem à l'assemblée
dans le même temps eh bien il s'agit de
ne pas froisser deux groupes
lrm en effet françois bayroux le chef du
modem a été nommé au plan tandis que
marc fresneau est toujours en poste en
tant que ministre des relations au
parlement on veut qu'à quoi qu'il en
soit et bien cette moisson de députés
permettra plus que jamais pour groupe
des centristes de faire pression sur le
groupe mrm prix pour parler de cette
rentrée politique en france et du
positionnement ou des tentatives en
photos de positionnement des différents
partis nous sommes avec alexis poulain
éditorialistes et notre nouvelle
rubrique l'édito bonsoir alexis poulain
ravi de vous retrouver pour cette
première yes dm ce soir la rentrée des
partis politiques on les a vu défiler
avec différentes état d'esprit
évidemment l air la république en marche
et rennes de nombreuses universités
d'été ce week-end et on commence avec un
petit coup d'oeil à gauche oui à gauche
avec cette rentrée en ordre dispersé il
ya eu le parti socialiste et levée la
france insoumise et puis les figures
tutélaires qui reviennent françois
hollande toujours là laurent joffrin qui
veut lancer un mouvement d'idées et
lionel jospin qui bien sûr un livret dit
que finalement emmanuel macron ne s'est
pas ancrée dans l'histoire il n'a été
qu'un moment et qui porte un jugement
assez dur sur le parti socialiste qui
n'est plus à même de rassembler autour
d'un projet projet que bien jean-luc
mélenchon compte bien poursuivre puisque
lui a dit que j'ai au moins lionel
jospin et dans le dialogue et pour le
leader de la france insoumise
il entend lui au contraire fédérer le
peuple ait lancé un mouvement d'une
nouvelle génération autour de son projet
donc vraiment on est on est dans un
moment politique où la gauche a bien du
mal à se trouver qui pourra être le
pivot central peut-être d'un candidat
d'unités pour 2022 c'est une majorité
d'adhésion qu'il faut qu'on
cuire si je suis candidat j'arriverai
efforts de mon bilan électoral de mon
expertise muni d'un programme ouvert
d'une brillante équipe soudée
idéologiquement est décidé à fonder avec
ceux qui l'auront voulu une nouvelle
force politique
cette force sera celle de la génération
suivante voilà ça c'est l interview de
l'ops dans lequel fond ce pardon de jean
luc mélenchon dérouler un peu ses idées
alors à droite
alexis visiblement la stratégie e 2022
et est loin d'être au clair là encore à
droite c'est plus compliqué il y avait
ce week end un rassemblement de jeunes
plus de nombreux jeunes qui étaient
autour de gérard larcher et des grands
pontes de la droite françois baroin
jette l éponge il n'a jamais vraiment
pris le lead mais il y avait cette idée
d'une candidature possible à la
candidature de françois baroin ce ne
sera pas le cas mais c'est christian
estrosi qui jette le trouble dans les
troupes de la droite en pensant
peut-être que la droite devrait faire
des manuels macron son candidat et se
rallier eh bien ce n'est pas du tout de
la vie de gérard larcher qui répondait
lors d'une matinale à une radio on
écoute je pense qu'il ya un espace c'est
le sens de mon combat
on ne peut pas se réduire un choix
binaire ou ignorer qu emmanuel macron où
marine le pen il ya un espace politique
pour la droite et le centre
je veux que les français aient le choix
voilà pourquoi je me bats pour cet
espace politique et surtout pour la
liberté de choix des français
certains voudraient nous faire croire qu
emmanuel macron serai un président de
droite pour une politique de droite
cette politique qui est conduite n'est
pas la nôtre mais voilà pour la réaction
de gérard larcher la gauche la droite et
le centre
alors le centre c'est encore une autre
histoire
katia technique en parlait à l'assemblée
nationale une hémorragie de députés
marcheurs la république en marche qui
attend toujours son nouveau leader à
l'assemblée et qui perd encore et
toujours et bien des députés
cette fois ci ils rejoignent les rangs
du modem et le modem et bien on peut
dire que ce parti a le vent en poupe
avec françois bayrou nommé au plan et
qui grossit ses rangs à l'assemblée
nationale ça pose question sur l'avenir
de
la république en marge puisque comme
lionel jospin le disait emmanuel macron
a du mal à centrer à s'ancrer dans
l'histoire reste à savoir si le projet
la république en marche peut durer après
l'échec aux municipales est ce que les
sénatoriales vont changer la donne est
ce qu'il y aura des candidats marcheurs
sous l'étiquette la république en marche
ou bien est ce que c'est le modem qui va
être fait oeuvre de roy
la question reste entière mais à voir la
façon dont françois bayrou revient dans
le jeu politique en au premier plan avec
ce rôle dans la planification bien et on
peut se demander comment va se faire une
coalition même si tout cela reste dans
une majorité présidentielle derrière
emmanuel macron moins soudé qu'avant
avec des groupes dissidents on est loin
bien sûr des frondeurs du ps
mais quand même il se passe quelque
chose d'à la république en marche et ce
n'est pas forcément du bon côté du moins
pour le groupe alors alexis enfin un mot
sur le thème de la sécurité il est
évidemment sur toutes les lèvres en
cette rentrée politique est ce que ce
sera l'un des grands enjeux de la
présidentielle
c'est du moins le jeu du moment
porté par gérald darmanin qui va
dérouler son plan demain et c'est
surtout bien sûr celui de marine le pen
qui tenait son université d'été et qui
en a fait un thème majeur comme toujours
d'ailleurs avec le front national reste
à savoir quelles vont être les moyens
pour ce plan sécurité et qu'elle peut
être aussi les moyens du rassemblement
national qui peine aujourd'hui à
recruter et bien des nouvelles recrues
et qui a fait une sorte de purge avec
les proches de marion maréchal-le pen
qui ont été mis un peu plus loin que de
la direction donc la sécurité oui c'est
le thème du moment est ce que ce thème
qui est cher à tous les français qui
réclament davantage de protection et de
sécurité va durer dans le temps jusqu'à
2022 ou bien est ce que gérald darmanin
va résoudre le problème rapidement avec
marlène schiappa bien ça reste à voir on
le verra dans les prochaines semaines
les prochains mois et dès demain avec la
présentation de ce plan sécurité et puis
et puis voir si d'autres thèmes vont
bien sûr arriver d'ici la fin d'année la
crise sanitaire bien sûr le bilan des
modèles macron mais chaque partie
aujourd'hui à un problème et ce problème
c'est les idées et le programme et il ya
encore du temps bien sûr mais les idées
sont au coeur du débat et du pain sur la
planche pour tousser
partie merci alexis poulain merci
d'avoir été avec nous alexeï navalni est
sorti du coma artificiel hier berlin n'a
toujours pas présenté les preuves de
l'empoisonnement de l'opposant russe
l'attend fait monter la pression côté
russe la porte parole de la diplomatie
maria sakharova dénonce dans cette
affaire un coup de bluff de la part de
berlin
la situation est trop sérieuse pour
permettre aux responsables allemands de
tout garder pour eux mêmes nous
attendons l'ambassadeur d'allemagne au
ministère des affaires étrangères il est
temps d'abattre les cartes car c'est une
évidence pour tout le monde
berlin bluff en alimentant un sinistre
jeu politique
mais on a appris ce soir que la france
reporter une réunion ministérielle
franco-russe informations du des
affaires étrangères les derniers détails
en tout cas de cette affaire n'avait ni
avec notre correspondant rta berlin
khiter olivier ce jeudi les docteurs à
omsk ont pris la parole
oms quelle ville ou alexeï navalni a
reçu les premiers soins
l'avion qui l'emmenait de sibérie à
moscou a dû atterrir en urgence à omsk
les docteurs sur place ont réfuté le
diagnostic des équipes berlinoise celui
de l'hôpital de la charité à berlin
selon lequel alexeï navalni a été
empoisonné avec un neurotoxique de type
nos vies de choc
il s'agissait il serait mort en l'espace
de quelques heures
ils disent avoir mené plus de 60 est
sans trouver la moindre trace de toxines
dans son système
il avait déjà proposé de mettre tous les
résultats de leurs tests disposition de
l'équipe médicale berlinoise ils
incitent leurs homologues allemands
de même est dévoilée l'épreuve les
données sur lesquelles se basent
l'accusation d'empoisonnement dans
l'excès une avanie alexeï navalni est
sorti du coma artificiel dans lequel il
avait placé les docteurs ce lundi il
n'est plus sous respirateur artificiel
et réagit à la parole mais il ya une
avalanche diplomatique à l'horizon
notamment autour du gazoduc north stream
2 qui est censé relier directement
l'allemagne à la russie en passant sous
la mer baltique
ce projet a déjà fait face à des menaces
notamment des menaces de lourdes
sanctions des états unis et à des
critiques de certains partenaires
européens
mais le discours de berlin jusqu'à
présent était qu'il s'agissait d'un
sujet à part un projet économique sur
lequel les autres événements n'avaient
pas d'incidence
cela pourrait bientôt changer ses deux
riches versent un possible successeur de
langue et la merkel à la chancellerie
après la fin de son mandat l'année
prochaine a déclaré qu'il imposerait
s'il était au pouvoir en ce moment même
un moratoire immédiat de deux ans sur le
projet north stream 2 la semaine
dernière d'autres responsables haut
placés du gouvernement allemand ont
évoqué l'idée d'un gel ou d'un abandon
pur et simple du projet sangay la merkel
cependant ce n'est pas à l'allemagne de
décider unilatéralement des conséquences
pour north stream 2 elle se traîne
approche paneuropéenne et se tourne vers
bruxelles concernant la recherche
d'informations supplémentaires sur la
ferme vanille au ministère des affaires
étrangères russe a fait part de son
mécontentement après la déclaration ce
lundi 2 et comme à ce ministre
affaires étrangères allemand selon ce
dernier les renseignements demandés par
moscou avait été transmis à la russie ce
que démentent les russes adorent
allemand un moscou a été convié au
ministère des affaires étrangères à ce
sujet selon la porte parole du ministère
des affaires étrangères russe maria
carrozza il est mauvais signe que la
russie n'ait pas reçu des informations
demandées et la réponse allemande et du
point de vue russe insuffisante
il s'agit de basses manoeuvres
politiques concernant l'état de santé
d'avec celles à venir
il est toujours hospitalisé ici à berlin
il est sorti du coma dans lequel il a
passé plus de deux semaines
il respire sans assistance est toujours
sous traitement à berlin et vous venez
de l'entendre la ferme nouvelle me
soulève bien des questions et suscite
beaucoup de réactions à l'international
pour tenter de décrypter l'envers du
décor nous sommes avec mériadec raffray
un journaliste spécialiste des questions
de défense secrétaire général de
l'association des journalistes de
défense
bonsoir mériadec raffray merci d'être
avec nous à ses côtés général françois
chauvancy général de brigade expert en
géostratégie bonsoir à vous également
général alors on va balayer la question
d'entrée de jeu votre avis sur cette
affaire la sphère navel ni pour vous
c'est quoi est ce que les choses
pourraient être finalement le compliqué
que ça en a l'air ou qu'on veut bien
nous les présentait on commence par vous
et mejia des tankers raffray bonsoir
stéphanie bah écoutez moi je constate
que vous les choses sont déjà très
compliqué elles sont bizarrement
compliqué d'ailleurs enfin bizarrement
je m'explique navel lino hitchock russie
c'est un cocktail détonnant et qui a
explosé sur la scène internationale à un
moment intéressant au moment où les
tensions internationales étaient fortes
sont fortes au moment où les alliés se
dispute sur la scène internationale pour
plusieurs dossiers je pense tout de
suite au dossier me dit méditerranéen
mais n'est pas seulement
au moment où les deux où les partisans
parlent et les les les membres de l'otan
se disputent
voilà pour une première réaction
générale souvent si votre comparse a
l'air de dire voilà que les choses sont
peut-être moins simple que ça en a l'air
qu'il ya en tout cas un contexte de
dossiers en cours et que cette affaire
est évidemment des a des répercussions
votre avis mais bon soir d'abord oui bah
je rejoindrai un petit peu ce qui vient
d'être dit par à mériadeck
avec peut-être en dissociant peut-être
les deux affaires je dirais mais des
deux à feu rouge par la première est une
affaire d'empoisonnement qui est une
réalité
donc il faut une explication soient les
démentis soit les valider par une
enquête
alors aujourd'hui on voit bien que d'un
côté on dit qu'il n'ya pas eu
d'empoisonnement de côté on dit qu'on a
eu un
déjà si on régler ce problème là ça
faciliterait les choses ça c'est le
premier point la deuxième affaire c'est
en fait l'exploitation de cette affaire
dont il ya des bugs convient d'évoquer
c'est un cocktail entre le poison la
russie un opposant oui il ya une
instrumentalisation de cette affaire
mais il n'y aurait pas d'
instrumentalisation
si les réponses claires était donné sur
la tentative d'assassinât ou peut-être
simplement un accident mais je ne suis
pas certain que ce vraiment un accident
et vous voulez dire un général des deux
côtés les questions ne sont pas données
parce qu'elles ne le sont pas plus du
côté de l'allemagne en attendent souvent
ses preuves d'empoisonnement à tout à
fait je suis d'accord avec vous il faut
de la clarté la transparence pour éviter
une aggravation de la situation
donc je crois qu'on est dans une
situation où personne ne veut assumer
des responsabilités
il y à des accusations je pense que
peut-être que quelqu'un un état doit
prendre la responsabilité de dire de
donner ce qu'il faut l'allemagne si elle
accuse elle doit apporter des preuves
l'épreuve est importé à la russie et
d'un autre côté ce que moi je n'ai pas
vu pour l'instant depuis plusieurs
semaines sk une enquête en russie sur
cette affaire et je crois que déjà si
l'aspect judiciaire et non pas politique
était réglé peut-être qu'il y aurait une
moindre affaire politique mais il n'y
avait qu'à voir après pourquoi c'est
aussi compliqué dans ce type d'affaires
à chaque fois de ne prouve
et voilà ce qu'on avance que ça soit du
côté russe comme du côté allemand
écoutez il ya 2 il ya deux choses il ya
d'abord premièrement le profil de
l'accusé ou de houe de la victime ça
dépend de quel côté on se place qui est
lui-même troubles à 1 présentée comme
hadopi opposiez opposants politiques à
poutine qui fait 3 % dans les intentions
de vote en 2018 en aux présidentielles
de 2018 c'est un tout petit opposants il
est on le sait bloqueurs lobbyistes
affairiste il a été condamné dans de
multiples affaires et en particulier
dans une affaire d'extorsion de fonds de
la société yves rocher en russie donc
c'est un c'est un garçon qui a à la fois
une oreille un passé un passif
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il est il est
avéré également qu'il a des liens avec
les états unis il est passé par yale
tout ça ajoute au trouble
ensuite il ya la partie politique
politicienne le berlin et moscou se
renvoie la charge de la preuve comme on
dit c'est ce que vient de dire les
général et à ce petit jeu là évidemment
impossible de distinguer qui a tort qui
a raison on se retrouve dans le même
schéma que la sphère skripal
et puis comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure on
y ajoute la sphère du fameux poison
novice choc un mot choc justement qui
tout de suite dramatise la faire et qui
lui aussi est un sujet en soi ultra
complexes que seule maîtrise à peu près
les spécialistes moi ce que je crois que
ce que je retiens de cette affaire c'est
que cette bombe explose à un moment
crucial sur le continent tout d'abord
elle mais l'allemagne face à ses propres
contradictions dans la sphère du gaz
nord stream une partie du monde des
affaires et des institutions donc porte
ce dossier une autre très atlantiste et
très pro otaniens à l'américaine et
contre celle ci évidemment sur la même
longueur d'onde que les états unis
autour de l'allemagne il ya un certain
nombre de pays qui sont très anti russe
et qui eux ne veulent absolument pas du
gazoduc non pas parce qu'ils sont anti
russe finalement mais parce qu'il ne
toucherait plus les subsides qu'ils
touchent grâce aux gazoducs terrestres
qui approvisionne l'europe
voilà c'est du côté du continent on voit
aussi que cette affaire explose au
moment où la campagne américaine reprend
d'ailleurs je note que peu trump au
passage a dit qu'on n'avait pas encore
des preuves d'un empoisonnement donc il
est assez prudent je me trompe on attend
de voir quelle sera la mission de maiden
et enfin et surtout et enfin alors les
grands la grande bretagne comme
d'habitude est très en pointe dans
l'offensive anti anti russe est une
tradition chez les britanniques
et qu'est ce qui se passe en france on
voit emmanuel macron qui est assez gêné
finalement aux entournures
moi je note si on prend un peu de recul
que le président macron devait doit se
rendre à moscou dans les jours les
semaines qui viennent la date
bizarrement on n'a toujours pas été
officialisée le voyage va t-il se
dérouler s'il se déroule ce des rades de
relative dans quelles conditions
là aussi cela pose question sur le
positionnement en fait de la france
vis-à-vis de la russie et vis-à-vis de
ses partenaires et enfin je le disais
tout à l'heure
cette affaire sem ou ou en tout cas
alimente la zizanie qui existe déjà dans
le la maison otanienne je vais vous
donner un exemple de cette izany qui est
aujourd'hui sur la place publique en
juin mi juin dernier la france a eu un
différend naval avec la turquie
le ministre de la défense français à a
demandé officiellement une enquête à
l'otan et celle ci s'est empressé de la
de mètres c'est le résultat sous le
boisseau
on sait que la turquie est un allié très
proche de washington et on sait
également que l'allemagne est un allié
politique de la turquie
voyez encore une nouvelle affaire qui
porte un fer dans le positionnement des
occidentaux visage vient de la russie en
tout cas merida qu'après vous avez
évoqué ce projet à nord stream
deux incertains interconnexion gazière
entre la russie et l'allemagne nous
avait d'ailleurs évoqué les états unis
après que berlin menacer de stopper ce
projet je me propose précisément
d'écouté donald trump avant de faire
réagir le général h odense et bien je
soutiens ça j'ai été le premier à en
parler vous n'avez jamais entendu parler
de nord stream 2 avant l'arrivée de
trump quand je suis arrivé j'ai dit
attendez une minute en protège
l'allemagne de la russie n'est ce pas
générale un changement si vous partagez
vous cette hypothèse ce gazoduc qui
serait peut-être aussi l'un des enjeux
en tout cas voilà qui tombe à pic dans
cette affaire une avanie ou ça vous
paraît alambiqué comme comme scénario ça
me semble à la fois en alambiquée mais
aussi plausible aujourd'hui nous sommes
effectivement dans la guerre du gaz
entre la russie et l'allemagne oublions
pas que l'allemagne est dépendante de la
russie pour le gaz la méditerranée et on
vient de parler mais regardez kraft
ferait effectivement la turquie qui veut
investir la méditerranée internationale
pour mettre la main sur les gisements de
gaz
on parle aussi au niveau de l'union
européenne de ce gazoduc qui viendraient
justement de ces champs gazier vers
l'europe pour réduire la dépendance
européenne du gaz russe et puis
effectivement trump qui par son gaz de
schiste souhaiterait le vendre à
l'europe
bon voila nous sort la guerre du gaz
alors maintenant nous sommes bien dans
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure dans
l'instrumentalisation une
instrumentalisation d'un fait divers
j'en resterai là je dirais pas un fait
politique un fait divers qui sert à de
multiples acteurs et effectivement la
complexité et est très difficile à
démêler qui a le meilleur intérêt à ce
que cette crise perdure que ce soit
l'otan je suis pas certain je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord là avec mériadec
raffray sur la place de l'otan sur son
positionnement
oui je suis d'accord sur le point
qu'elle n'a pas soutenu la france ça
c'est une réalité mais bon à la limite
on a toutes les organisations
internationales que l'on mérite
les organismes internationales ne sont
pas toujours est loin d'être capable de
gérer des affaires nationales et des
intérêts nationaux
donc méfiance effectivement mais que ce
soit directement liée à l affaire dont
nous parlons je n'en suis pas sûr
maintenant il ya un problème de
dépendance du gard à ces deux réalités
et avec différents acteurs la complexité
je suis un cas pas aujourd'hui de vous
dire qui est le réel coupables réels
acteurs derrière qui tire les ficelles
c'est un ensemble maintenant il faut
garder raison et puis finalement prendre
un peu de recul un peu de calme et voir
un petit peu dans le temps comment les
choses vont se dérouler une chose est
sûre c'est qu'on l'a dit tout à l'heure
à la france comporte une réunion
ministérielle franco russe a des
conséquences diplomatiques alors qu'on
sait que la russie et la france
leur relation en tout cas se réchauffer
berlare acquis voilà parle d'arrêter ce
projet est ce qu'on peut imaginer que
les états unis joue un petit rôle là
dedans c'est rapidement s'il vous plaît
mériadec raffray
moi ce que je constate en tout cas c'est
que si la france a reporté une réunion
ministérielle la journée je dirais dans
le dans la posture officielle ce que ce
qu'il faut voir c'est que la russie va
sans doute très prochainement jouer un
rôle fondamental à jouer à nouveau un
rôle fondamental en méditerranée
orientale cette fois en se posant en
conciliateur entre les grecs et les
turcs dont on voit que de toute façon la
russie qu'elle soit coupable ou victime
dans cette affaire va jouer dé facto un
rôle important et majeur dans les
principaux dossiers de tensions
internationales actuelles c'était hier
plutôt proche orient c'est aujourd'hui
en méditerranée orientale où le général
chauve ans il a rappelé elle surveille
aussi les manoeuvres autour des pays qui
veulent mettre la main sur les réserves
de gaz découvertes au sud au large de la
chine qui je le rappelle ont
l'équivalent pratiquement l'équivalent
du gisement
actua en mer du nord donc de toute façon
et ce n'est pas le cas des etats-unis
aujourd'hui de toute façon dans les
semaines qui viennent la russie sera un
des maîtres du jeu du tapis
méditerranéen pendant que les etats unis
eux sont tourner d'abord vers leurs
crises sanitaires et ensuite dans leurs
querelles politiques dont ils l'ont on
voit du mal à sortir
merci en tout cas à tous les deux nous
avoir apporté votre point de vue
mériadec raffray journalistes
spécialisés testons défense secrétaire
général de l'association des
journalistes de défense et le général
françois chauvancy général de brigade
expert en géostratégie
merci à vous deux il est presque 20h30
en direct sur arte france merci de nous
rejoindre on va évoquer ces
affrontements à minsk contre la police
antiémeutes et des manifestants alors
qu'une centaine de protestataires se
sont rassemblés dans la capitale
biélorusse en soutien à maria
kolesnikova cette militante de
l'opposition est détenu à la frontière
avec l'ukraine
son arrestation intervient après qu'elle
ait résisté aux tentatives des autorités
de l'expulser du pays lors d'une
manifestation ont pillé loukachenko
cette dernière est pour le moment sous
la garde des autorités biélorusses et si
la biélorussie tombe à la prochaine sera
la russie c'est en tout cas ce qu'a
déclaré le président biélorusse
alexandre loukachenko dans un entretien
accordé à plusieurs médias russes la
biélorussie en proie à des mouvements de
contestation depuis près d'un mois
contre la réélection contestée du chef
de l'état ce n'est pas la russie ni la
biélorussie qui l'ont initié c'est eux
qui s'en sont toujours occupés et ils
l'ont eu
que dieu s'occupe d'eux et nous
récoltons les fruits de tout ça abolir
internet et le reste même si on abolit
internet aujourd'hui les chaînes
télégramme continueront à fonctionner
depuis la pologne
donc ce n'est pas le moment de vous
relâcher vous allez également avoir
bientôt certains événements politiques
et probablement sans aucune raison
vous savez où nous en sommes arrivés
avec l'establishment et les dirigeants
russes
si aujourd'hui la biélorussie s'effondre
la russie sera la prochaine et pour en
parler nous sommes avec un k reen bêcher
gaulle au fco professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou bonsoir
merci avec
karine bêcher goal of co tout d'abord
cette déclaration frechin du président
bélarusse alexandre loukachenko qui
estime que si son régime tomber la
russie suit vrai que vous inspire cette
affirmation ce qu'elle consent bloc
crédible bon sur cette affirmation me
semble en effet pleine de bon sens
malheureusement parce que lorsque l'on
voit les crises qui se développe aux
frontières de la russie
petit à petit il est évident que la
russie fait l'objet d'une opération
d'encerclement de la part du plan
globaliste avec l'aide de l'otan
donc après l'ukraine il est tout à fait
logique que la la biélorussie et d'été
attaqué la période électorale comme à
chaque fois est toujours privilégiée
puisque c'est une période qui permet de
jouer en fait sur la transition du
pouvoir
et si la transition ne permet pas de
mettre en place un candidat qui soit
sûre européen
dans ce cas là c'est l'occasion de
affaiblir afin de faire tomber un
système tout cas de faire tomber un
système qui est déjà affaibli parce qu
en général et les systèmes politiques
sont assez affaibli en ce moment sur ce
que en occident ils sont pas sous
pression des révolutions qui sont déjà
dans leurs locaux distincts donc
effectivement derrière les vélos et s'il
a de fortes chances que soit la russie
puisqu'il ya une configuration politique
qui ressemble à en quelque sorte
beaucoup de traits même si la russie a
beaucoup plus de force que le bel olo
alors aujourd'hui ans est l'une des
déclarations également de la soirée en
paris condamne les arrestations qu'elle
définit comme arbitraire et l'exil forcé
d'opposants via le ministère des
affaires étrangères qu'elle peut être
justement la marge la marge de manoeuvre
de ces pays dont la france dans cette
affaire biélorusse
la marge de manoeuvre est ca de la
volonté ses dirigeants le problème étant
de savoir que manifestement ils n'ont
aucune envie de regarder ce qui se passe
lorsque l'on parle de l'exil forcé c'est
assez surprenant
est-ce que thuram ce qu'a été obligé de
partir ou bien les parties elles mêmes
tout seul très rapidement d'ailleurs
lorsque manifestement comme attendu elle
a perdu ce qui d'ailleurs était prévu et
ce qui était nécessaire pour pouvoir
lancer toute cette affaire
en ce qui concerne le départ des trois
membres du conseil de coordination de
l'opposition
il ya différentes aires ci ont quand
même qui circulent parce qu'il ya la
version à magnifique romanesque
fabuleuse de ses opposants qui ne veut
pas partir qu'ils sont obligés qu'ils
ont été obligés de prendre avec eux dans
leur dans leur voiture quel est le cas
des semis cauvin qui a été partie du
présidium de cette de ce conseil
or il ya aussi une autre version
pas du tout celle où cette jeune femme
forcé à partir en ukraine sort de la
voiture des sites déchire son passeport
et se dirigent courageusement vers le
kgb
il ya celles qui est plutôt dévoilée par
les garde-frontières qui explique à 4
heures du matin les kills voyant que le
contrôle aux frontières avec l'ukraine
été renforcées a foncé vers des
gardes-frontières que afin de faire une
vidéo de diversion et de pouvoir passer
ces deux charmants amis de l'opposition
l'ont littéralement jeté en dehors de la
voiture ce qui a conduit effectivement à
son arrestation c'est une vision qui
comme beaucoup moins belle mais qui
permet d'expliquer aussi pourquoi tout à
coup il ya à nouveau des manifestations
tout son soutien à l ils ont enfin une
victime s'écrit fille que tu iras
lorsqu'un depuis le temps qu'elle et à
l'étranger commencent à avoir du mal à
remplir sa fonction
enfin une chose est sûre c'est que la
contestation rassemble environ un cent
mille personnes chaque jour dans les
rues de minsk s'est tout de même un
message qu'il faut entendre de la part
du pouvoir
il ya effectivement un message entendre
mme on a vu aussi la différence entre
peut-être l'aspiration des ukrainiens en
2014 et ce qui a été fait une fois que
le pouvoir a entendu message et sous
l'égide de pays européens a signé un
accord avec l'opposition pour ensuite le
lendemain est persécuté et de voir
s'enfuir du pays sinon être celle ci
n'est la question de savoir ce que cela
va aider labello ici si loukachenko
reprenant l'expérience ukrainienne de
2014 va à nouveau discuter avec
l'opposition sous l'égide des européens
en risquant lui aussi il ya de fortes
chances derrière effectivement de 2 vers
le devoir s'enfuir
quel sera l'état de la biélorussie après
quand on regarde l'état de l'ukraine
aujourd'hui donc le changement c'est
très bien mais la question de savoir
pourquoi
loukachenko est tout à fait conscient
d'ailleurs il l'a déclaré dans son
interview aujourd'hui que tête c'est un
petit peu longtemps qu'il est au pouvoir
et ça c'est le problème effectivement de
ce régime c'est que il est concentré
autour s'est concentrée l'auteur d'une
personne et lorsque vous avez une figure
très forte qui a demandé qui domine
l'espace politique
objectivement une réelle opposition a du
mal à se développer mais il faut voir
aussi que l'occident aime beaucoup ce
genre de configuration
parce que ça permet de dessécher et
d'affaiblir le pays de l'intérieur
et lorsque nous cache un codic derrière
le vélo ici c'est là aussi parce que
cette question se pose aussi en russie
et l'on voit la grande difficulté de
transition de l'après poutine en russie
donc les questions se posent oui il y a
un problème
mais est ce que ça veut dire que il faut
absolument tout accepter tout et
n'importe comment
lorsque l'on voit aussi quand même qu'
il y à sers beaucoup de personnes dans
les rues sur les chiffres c'est toujours
une grande difficulté quand même pour
apprécier les chiffres donc on va pas
rentrer dans les détails il ya du monde
c'est ce qui compte
mais
la question fondamentale qui reste étant
de savoir dans quelle mesure s
complètement naturel ou n'est-ce pas
aussi passablement manipuler rappelons
quand même qu'il ya quelques millions
d'euros qui ont été débloqués par mignon
européenne sous couvert de lutte contre
le vide qui sont adressées directement
la société civile parce qu'il est
évident que quand vous êtes malade et
vous c'est sony pour déménager merci
karine michel collot vaut d'avoir été
avec nous avoir apporté votre point de
vue votre analyse en direct un sur rt
france emmanuel macron a reçu à paris
son homologue ivoirien alassane ouattara
ce dernier annoncé sa candidature un
troisième mandat controversée à la
présidentielle du 31 octobre
c'est ce qu'ont indiqué les présidences
française et ivoirienne depuis cette
annonce le pays est secoué par des
manifestations une rencontre à paris aux
herbes campagne présidentielle
ivoirienne décrié précisément par
l'opposition les explications de monaco
dès lors c'est un véritable ultimatum
que les chefs de l'état de la cedeao ont
lancé aux nouvelles autorités maliennes
de bamako il donne une semaine à la
gente militaire pour désigner un
président de transition ainsi que son
premier ministre
toutes les sanctions prises à l'encontre
de la junte sont maintenus en attendant
ibrahim boubacar keita a été autorisé à
quitter le territoire pour rejoindre les
émirats arabes unis pour se faire
soigner
le mali a été un sujet longuement abordé
par emmanuel macron l ivoirien alassane
ouattara lors de leur rencontre à paris
il y a quelques jours une rencontre
discrète et pour cause
alassane ouattara entend briguer un
troisième mandat présidentiel en côte
d'ivoire suite au soudain décès à
d'amadou gon coulibaly ch
pourtant en mars il avait annoncé ne pas
se représenter une déclaration alors
saluée par emmanuel macron je salue la
décision historique du président
ouattara homme de parole et hommes
d'état de ne pas se présenter à la
prochaine élection présidentielle
ce soir la côte d'ivoire donne l'exemple
finalement ouattara est de retour dans
la course depuis ça
annonce le pays est secoué par des
manifestations à travers le pays ayant
fait au moins une quinzaine de morts
malgré la candidature de ouattara est un
pays sens dessus dessous
silence radio du côté de la france un
difficile jeu d'équilibriste pour
emmanuel macron qui tente on encourage
ouattara à ne pas se représenter pour
finalement l'accueillir à bras ouverts
alors qu'il est candidat
un revirement qui semble aujourd'hui
maître paris dans l'embarras qui se
passerait volontiers d'une nouvelle
crise électorale en côte d'ivoire
au vu de tous les intérêts français sur
le plan économique la côte d'ivoire est
le premier partenaire commercial de
paris au sein de la zone franc cfa et le
deuxième en afrique subsaharienne
du côté militaire les forces françaises
bénéficient d'un statut de force de
présence et constitue l'une des deux
bases opérationnelles avancées en
afrique
emmanuel macron un final à sa doctrine
du en même temps veut être présent mais
sans trop l'être
reste que cette visite a comme un air de
campagne présidentielle ivoirienne dans
l'hexagone alors que le chef de l'état
avait répété à plusieurs reprises qu'il
fallait se débarrasser et des vestiges
de la françafrique
je suis d'une génération de français
pour qui les crimes de la colonisation
européenne sont incontestables et font
partie de notre histoire
je suis d'une génération où l'on ne
vient pas dire à l'afrique ce qu'elle
doit faire
quelles sont les règles de l'état de
droit mais où partout on encouragera
celles et ceux qui en afrique veulent
prendre leurs responsabilités en
attendant cette rencontre sonne comme
une acceptation pour l'opposition
ivoirienne votre parole est très attendu
en ne cautionnant pas ce coup de force
institutionnel en exigeant des élections
transparentes et inclusives vous serez
fidèle aux valeurs démocratiques issues
des lumières dont la france est porteuse
puisque en vous exprimant une première
fois vous êtes désormais partie prenante
dans le débat politique ivoirien
votre silence face à la forfaiture qui
se dessine serait incompréhensible pire
aux yeux de beaucoup il vaudrait
complicité à nicolas sarkozy françois
hollande emmanuel macron tous avaient
déclaré
vouloir changer la politique africaine
de la france
mais la françafrique semble avoir la vie
dure et l'ascendant de la france sur le
continent africain pourrait toujours
être en marche
théophile kouamouo journaliste afrique
pour le média revient sur la position d'
emmanuel macron concernant un troisième
mandat d'alassane ouattara l'opposition
ivoirienne disons qu'elle est plutôt
satisfaite des des bruits des fuites qui
indique que emmanuel macron a expliqué
alassane ouattara est une très mauvaise
idée ce troisième mandat et qu'il
fallait reporter les élections pour
organiser un scrutin inclusif avec entre
guillemets la nouvelle génération
en tout cas qu'une partie de
l'opposition je pense que il ya une
parti d'opposition qui a intérêt à ce
que le scrutin soit reporté d'autres
partis comme henri colombier par exemple
pdci qui a intérêt à ce que ce scrutin
se joue dans ces conditions là parce que
sont malgré tout les conditions les plus
propices à une arrivée au pouvoir disent
on l'espère il compte sur le report des
voix des autres opposants qui sont
empêchés de se présenter
donc a priori disons la prise de
distance dernière macron vis-à-vis
d'alassane ouattara une bonne nouvelle
pour l'opposition ivoirienne mais
l'opposition à elle n'est pas puni
derrière même mot d'ordre une stratégie
l'afrique du sud et son économie frappée
une crise qui provoque une chute
impressionnante du pib au deuxième
trimestre les précisions avec florian
lambert
du jamais vu dans l'histoire de la
première économie du continent africain
le produit intérieur brut de l'afrique
du sud s'est effondré de 51% en deuxième
trimestre une récession sans précédent
qui frappe un pays déjà durement éprouvé
par la situation sanitaire
l'afrique du sud compte le plus grand
nombre de victimes du coc vite 19 sur le
continent africain avec elle de 15 mille
morts à ce jour le 27 mars dernier afin
de freiner la propagation du coronavirus
le gouvernement sud-africain mettait en
place un confinement strict de huit
semaines en limitant les déplacements de
la population au détriment des activités
économiques
conséquence directe l'effondrement du
pib en grande partie due au fort recul
des secteurs de la construction de
l'industrie manufacturière et de
l'exploitation minière
trois secteurs qui accuse une baisse
d'activité de plus de 70%
leader de la production minière avec les
trois quarts de la production mondiale
et deuxième pays producteur d'or au
monde l'afrique du sud regorge de
ressources naturelles mais voit ses
exportations sombré depuis le début de
la pandémie avec un chômage de masse et
un état qui n'a plus d'argent les
inégalités sociales dans le pays ne
cesse de croître
[Musique]
selon le programme des nations unies
pour le développement
l'extrême pauvreté pourrait y bondir de
plus de 60% dans les prochains mois
après la crise sanitaire
une crise sociale majeure est d'ores et
déjà en train de frapper les sud
africains dans un récent rapport la
banque mondiale décrit l'afrique du sud
comme le pays le plus inégalitaire au
monde
[Musique]
il rend par la présence du break site
avec le dernier round des négociations
qui reprend dans un contexte de tension
entre les deux camps bruxelles est clair
il n'y aura pas de retour sur les
engagements pris c'est pourtant ce
qu'envisage boris johnson si aucun
accord n'était trouvé
londres reconnaît toutefois que la
révision prévue de l'accord du break
site viole le droit international
les explications d'hélène masquelier
avec claire pissavy yvernault la crainte
d'un new deal plane plus que jamais sur
la future relation entre les deux
parties alors que débute le huitième
round de leur négociation la tension
monte d'un cran entre britanniques et
européens
boris johnson se dit prêt à claquer la
porte à la mi octobre faute de compromis
l'on rappelle bruxelles à plus de
pragmatisme lieu doit faire preuve de
plus de réalisme sur notre statut en
tant que pays indépendant
nous ne pouvons plus nous permettre de
ressasser les mêmes choses après six
mois de dialogue
selon les informations du financial
times le gouvernement britannique
pourrait revenir sur ses engagements
passés
londres envisagerait de présenter dès ce
mercredi un projet de loi visant à élire
la portée juridique de certaines parties
de l'accord notamment en ce qui concerne
les réglementations douanières en
irlande du nord
une manoeuvre décrié par bruxelles tout
ce qui a été signé dans le passé doit
être respectée c'est le gage de la
confiance pour l'avenir il n'y aura pas
de compromis pas d'accord avec le
royaume uni au détriment de l'union
européenne et au détriment du marché
unique
si l'europe dénonce l'attitude du
royaume uni le parlement britannique a
lui même reconnu aujourd'hui qu'une
révision de l'accord poserait problème
oui cela viole le droit international de
manière très spécifiques et limités
nous prenons le pouvoir de faire
disparaître le concept d'effet direct du
droit de l'ue eux exigé par l'article 4
dans certaines circonstances très
étroitement définis
il existe des précédents clair pour le
royaume-uni est en fait d'autres pays
qui doivent tenir compte de leurs
obligations internationales
à mesure que les circonstances changent
à l'heure actuelle les négociations
butent notamment sur la pêche et les
conditions de concurrence équitables si
aucun accord n'est trouvé
les relations entre l'union européenne
et le royaume uni serait régi par les
règles de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce
avec à la clé des droits de douane
élevés et des contrôles aux frontières
plus poussée un scénario qui
pénaliserait davantage européens et
britanniques
et pour en parler nous sommes avec un
paul thompson vice-président du parti
conservateur britannique en france
bonsoir voila
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france le royaume uni qui reconnaît un
vouloir revenir sur certains engagements
en violation du droit international
s'exposant à de graves conséquences de
la part de bruxelles telle est la
stratégie britannique
encore un coup de bluff la part de boris
johnson je pense que c'est une tentative
de déjà fait une pression maximale comme
dirait notre promenade en cours et les
sanctions mais je pense que c'est dans
cet état d'esprit que il est juste de la
sorte mais ça ne veut pas d'un coup je
dois pas parce qu'un coup de bluff
voudrait dire que on ne n'étais pas
vraiment prête à donner suite je n'y
avait rien derrière
ici il est fort possible que le but du
gouvernement sur cette disposition
précise qu' et qui apparemment intégré
dans un projet de loi être présenté
demain je pense que c'est l'intention
réelle de 2 de faire passer cette
disposition je le suppose et en ce qui
concerne l'éventualité d'une d'un
absence d'accord donc une séparation à
la fin de la période de transition qui
se termine le 31 12
je crois que boris johnson d'une part et
réellement prêts à à accepter ce
résultat si les choses se termine ainsi
mais que d'autre part il vend au vrai
très sérieusement pour parvenir à un
accord et il il suppose que ça se fera
dans la dernière ligne droite
en tout cas il a l'air de dire que voilà
il menace de quitter la table des
négociations à la mi-août hommes c'est
un accord de libre échange mais n'était
pas trouvée
vous pensez vraiment paul thompson qu'il
ira jusqu'au bout il l'air de dire que
le no deal finalement c'est pas si mal
pour les britanniques mais enfin qu'en
pensent les principaux intéressés au
sein de la population britannique c'est
ce que si c'était ou que vous faites
allusion
les avis sont variés comme cas depuis le
début du sag âme du break site
encore une fois je pense que il vise un
deal mais il faut regarder à ce qui se
passe de l'autre côté de la table de
négociation avec la position de l'union
européenne des 27 est quand même à
rigide sur des sujets absolument
fondamentaux par exemple elle vivait
elle doit munich 1 ils doivent
simplement sa ligne elle sera sauvée
règles européennes de façon assez
générale alors que chacun sait que le
tout le but du break 6 et près de 2 de
revenir à plus de contrôle sur sur ses
choix politiques restaient buté sur
cette position pour moi est vraiment là
pour le coup totalement irréaliste et je
suppose que les l'union européenne
prévoit déjà de de revenir en arrière
dans une certaine mesure toute la
question de savoir ce qu'elle proposera
comme comme compromis de même prétendre
que dans les zones de pêche du royaume
uni tout doit continuer comme avant
alors que ce sont des eaux territoriales
du royaume uni est assez surprenant pour
pour moi donc bonne chance je jeu mais
j'imagine très fortement se dit qu'il a
en face à michel barnier qui a table
assez obtus qui refuse de bouger sur des
ce point absolument fondamentaux et que
le sang ne lui laisse guère
le choix que de d'être aussi difficile
mais tout en espérant que encore une
fois dans la dernière ligne droite les
les grands décideurs dernier n'est pas
un des grands décideurs à se
concerteront a accru ses parts à côté de
grands décideurs et lui par exemple
qu'il est intelligent pragmatique qui
attache beaucoup d'importance à des
relations banny constructive avec le
voyons paris n'est pas le fruit tant
qu'homme et tout espoir n'est pas perdu
merci beaucoup par thomson vice
président du parti conservateur
britannique en france d'avoir été avec
nous et avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du corona virus en france
avec les laboratoires pris d'assaut le
test du premier ministre jean castex
identifié en tant que cas contact s'est
révélé négatif et puis non viendront sur
la rentrée des classes en seine saint
denis alors que plusieurs milliers
d'élèves manquent à l'appel
[Musique]
en pleine crise du coroner virus après
avoir constaté l'incapacité de l'union
européenne à manifester la moindre
solidarité envers des etam l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise la montée
en puissance de la chine dans le
commerce mondial a évidemment réduit le
poids de l'euro il faut y ajouter la
fragmentation de la zone et son
incapacité à parler d'une seule voix la
rend beaucoup moins attractif il est
évident que le projet politique d'une
véritable union est mort entre des
membres trop différente est trop long la
vraie question est de savoir si le
président français va vouloir et pouvoir
rebondir et comment les choix sont
multiples mais tout le problème va être
bien choisi
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez qu'avec cette
candidature a dû pdc y votre parti reste
crédible
à partir du moment où le plaisir et
colombier revient en bourse
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie et
retrouver la cohésion sociale que nous
avons perdu malheureusement on peut
réellement parler de climat
insurrectionnel en côte d'ivoire si on
permettait aux ivoiriens de manifester
est libre d'exprimer leurs opinions en
toute liberté
il n'y aurait pas de démission nous
allons retrouver le pouvoir gagner ces
élections et il n'y aura pas de chasse
aux sorcières que les partisans du rhdp
se rassurent nous n'allons pas les
poursuivre on les fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation vraie d ivoirité
[Musique]
votre gouvernement et notre gouvernement
ainsi que tous les autres grands
gouvernements du monde savent ce qui va
se passer et quand ça va se passer a
vendu mais ne nous ont pas dit et ils ne
me l'ont pas dit match que vous pouvez
imaginer quelque chose de si grands que
la terre faire ça cela va provoquer les
raz-de-marée les tremblements de terre
et éruptions
la terre va s'incliner ça va être payant
c'est le col de mon grand père personne
ne se soucierait des lois ou d'aller en
prison
illégalité prospérerait et la vie
deviendrait insupportable
malheureusement ici on écoute ceux qui
ne sont pas d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce coup ci c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
ici au delà du cercle polaire sur le
plateau continental russe l'homme
extrait du pétrole arctique pour la
première fois la russie est le premier
pays à avoir une plateforme sous ces
latitudes
d'autres états ont fait des tentatives
mais ont tous échoué
[Musique]
les conditions de travail sont
extrêmement sévères c'est dangereux
la tension est maximale aux étapes
d'aproz le navire est très proche de la
plateforme à 80 m on peut dire que la
plateforme est à portée de main
chaque jour qui passe est une occasion
de vérifier le professionnalisme des
équipes mais des imprévus surviennent
aussi
alerte à l'attention du personnel de la
plateforme rejoignez immédiatement les
points de rassemblement
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
parlement qui vote de grands objectifs
massif à peu à la manière des plans
quinquennaux soviétique le soutien à
l'éolien c'est entre 70 et 90 milliards
d'euros
la facture d'électricité des français va
forcément monte désormais ses financés
par les taxes qui remporte sur le
carburant là les fameuses taxes
d'ailleurs qui ont provoqué la colère
des gilet jaune en fait violence pour
faire de l'écologie est tombé assez
difficile d'expliquer aux gens que on
laboure les fonds marins ont détruit un
écosystème humain économique et tout ça
pour le bien de la planète
[Musique]
mais
bonsoir merci nous rejoindre pour cette
deuxième heure d'émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi 8 septembre
en france le premier ministre jean
castex testées négatives trois jours
après avoir côtoyé le directeur du tour
de france tester lui positif
emmanuel macron appelle les français à
mieux respecter des gestes barrières
lors de réunions privées alors que de
nouvelles mesures de lutte contre le
virus seront examinés vendredi au cours
d'un conseil de défense environ 3900
enfants attendus dans les écoles de
seine-saint-denis ne sont pas retournés
en classe c'est cinq fois plus que
d'habitude déménagement hooper ducobu 19
le ministère cherche à comprendre en
affirmant que ce chiffre n'est qu'une
estimation alors que ton parler de lexis
ou de peur l'éducation nationale
fait-elle son travail est elle
suffisamment bien géré la situation
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir l'espagne pays le plus touché
d'europe par la seconde vague du kobe 19
il a passé la barre des 500 milles
contamination et le taux d'incidence du
virus
106 cas pour 100000 habitants est deux
fois plus élevé qu'en france environ un
tiers de ces nouveaux cas ont été
relevés dans la région de la capitale
madrid épicentre de l'épidémie comme au
printemps
[Musique]
en outre atlantique le vaccin au coeur
des débats en vue de l'élection
présidentielle président américain
donald trump un fish cette confiance et
promet un antidote d'ici novembre et
accusent le candidat démocrate joe biden
de développer je cite une rhétorique
anti vaccins irresponsable
[Musique]
le premier ministre à tester donc
négatif mais qui restent isolés jean
castex est considéré comme un cas de
contact après avoir côtoyé samedi
dernier le directeur du tour de france
christian prudhomme
ce dernier lui a été testé positif
encore aux navires us aujourd'hui le
premier ministre était à ses côtés dans
une voiture lors de la 8e étape du tour
de france homme et cette question en
présent faut-il oui ou non on réduire la
période d'isolement des personnes
contaminées au kobe 19 et des caps
contact précisément oui pour le conseil
scientifique mis en place par le
gouvernement qui a donné un avis
favorable en ce sont celles est de 14
jours actuellement et pourrait donc être
raccourcie à sept jours la décision
devrait être prise lors du prochain
conseil de défense vendredi et un
problème justement pour les personnes
symptomatique et des cas contacts qui
doivent observer une période d'isolement
les files d'attentes qui s'allonge
désespérément ont des centres de test en
france et les délais pour obtenir les
résultats qui sont de plus en plus long
on en parle avec vous thomas abonnés
notre reporter thomas vous êtes bonsoir
vous êtes à vous même qu'à contacter 1
et dans les tentes de vos résultats
expliqué nous un petit peu comment ça se
passe en effet depuis famille après
avoir côtoyé une personne qui a été
testée positive au coronavirus j'ai dû
patienter d'abord pendant sept jours
afin de me faire psp et là c'était le
début des difficultés en région
parisienne et laboratoires sont
surchargés vous l'avez dit certains ne
prennent que sur rendez vous et il faut
parfois attendre plusieurs jours avant
d'avoir un credo j'ai donc dû me rendre
dans les centres de dépistage déployés
par la ville de paris un poste gratuit
sans rendez vous et qui s'obtient après
un peu de patience tu peux attendre plus
d'une heure pour réaliser le test est
encore dans certains endroits la tente
peut être bien plus longue
on a ensuite indiqué que passe à la
forte affluence les résultats ne me
serais communiqué que cinq jours plus
tard il faut savoir que dans le même
centre de dépistage
quelques jours plus tôt le délai
d'obtention de ces tests d'état lors de
48 heures cela pose plusieurs problèmes
déjà n'y avait pas de hiérarchie dation
ans mathilde attente il y avait aussi
bien des cas contacts comme moi que des
personnes avec des symptômes mais aussi
des personnes qui souhaitent se faire
tester avant un voyage par exemple
c'est une des raison de l'engorgement
des centres de test et c'est pour cela
que certains médecins appelle justement
à cibler davantage certains profils dans
la campagne de tests les cas contacts et
les personnes symptomatique serait un
site prioritaire c'est un engorgement
qui a des conséquences importantes
puisque on le rappelle art on l'a déjà
dit que dans certains cas il est demandé
d'observer une période d'isolement mais
c'est le cas évidemment pour les
personnes qui ressentent des symptômes
de la maladie mais aussi pour les
personnes qui ont été en contact avec un
malade
jusqu'à présent les personnes testées
positives et les cas contacts devaient
s'isoler pendant deux semaines une
période qui pourrait donc être réduite à
une semaine suite à un avis favorable du
conseil scientifique pour danser ce
mardi la décision sera tranché vendredi
prochain lors d'un conseil de défense
cela permettra de moins pénaliser des
personnes concernées mais aussi de
renforcer l'adhésion à ce principe car
selon le ministre de la santé ou lille
et veyran de nombreux français ne
respectent pas cette période ni
isolation il ya aussi des gens qui ne
souhaitent tout simplement pas se faire
tester justement pour éviter d'être
contrainte de se confiner à nouveau
l'autre axe pour le gouvernement c'est
de mettre en place des tests plus rapide
des tests ni en privé knicks vont être
déployés cette semaine il permet
d'obtenir les résultats en une vingtaine
de minutes
reste maintenant à voir en quelle
l'ombre ils seront disponibles en
attendant les tests défaire reste la
norme 1 million de tests sont réalisés
chaque semaine selon olivier ferrand
mais les délais sont donc toujours aussi
long pour avoir les résultats et en ce
qui me concerne et bien j'attends tout
et bon courage
thomas abonnés et patience et ces
derniers chiffres du commis de 19 en
france elles ne sont pas mieux ce soir
6544 cas supplémentaires en 24 heures un
chiffre en hausse par rapport à yerres
91 nouveaux foyers de contamination ont
été détectés 71 départements sont
désormais classés en situation de
vulnérabilité modérée ou élevée autre
chiffon ce le nombre de décès en milieu
hospitalier il est de 39 ce soir et pour
en parler de cette crise sanitaire nous
sommes avec bertrand legrand médecins
généralistes auteur du journal d'un
médecin au temps du coronavirus aux
éditions de l'archipel fois docteur le
grand merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors expliquez nous vous
comment vous le vivez dans votre cabinet
on vous a souvent eu ici sur ce plateau
à distance c'est maintenant les flux de
patients pour pour des tests pcr
c'est bien ça surtout l'application les
flux et dont on est haut rhin où je
retrouve 150% de mon optique vous voyez
je vous retrouve avec un secrétariat qui
est incapable de répondre au téléphone
dans 85% des cas film est jamais arrivé
en 15 ans d'exercice et même pas pendant
qu'on filme en plus on a énormément de
patients symptomatiques qui
nécessiterait d'avoir un fpr et c'est
bien inquiétant quand on entend les bd
que vous avez quinze jours avec un test
vestaires a pour but de permettre aux
allemands vont pas de vous-mêmes mail
isolement des cas contacts que vous avez
eue et surtout des contacts devant
quelques contacts
donc si on continue cette politique de
tester les gens agissent elles quand
elles sont quelque part ils joueront
leurs résultats gillis et ne vont pas
nous la compteront simplement et c'est
un vrai problème faut savoir quelle est
la stratégie est ce que c'est juste la
montée alors comment faudrait-il faire
docteur le grand pour que ça soit plus
efficace pour la contrer
la première des choses c'est que chaque
français se doit aujourd'hui alors que
des tourments à fin prêt d'explosion si
vous voulez de faire très attention à
diminuer son nombre de cas qu ils ne
pourront plus prendre autant qu'elle
contacte en charge ce n'est pas possible
haymoz plus s est retracée ou simplement
les contacts des positif il faut être
raisonnable
vous devez vous masquez vous devez
limiter au contact dans la mesure du
possible limiter les fêtes les mariages
et compagnie ça n'est pas possible j'ai
encore testé aujourd'hui toute une
famille s'était rendu un mariage la
semaine dernière donc on ne peut plus
vraiment on vous demande d'être
raisonnable et si vous ne les tra le
prix à payer en sera un confinement qui
est impossible dans un but économique
donc vraiment c'est la responsabilité de
chacun qui fera qu' on arrivera à une
telle idée mais on a besoin de calme
sérénité
on entend bien cet appel un set au
français une chose est sûre concernant
les tests les autorités misent désormais
sur les tests anti génie qui seront
déployés cette semaine en ile-de-france
donc plus rapide
il détecte en revanche apparemment un
petit peu moins d'individus infectés que
l'examen par pcf ça vous semble est
quand même un bon début une bonne chose
en fait il faut expliquer aux français
quelque chose de très simple c'est que
l'on ne teste pas quelqu'un pour dans le
but d'y annoncer un diagnostic on ne le
faisait pas pour les pcr ne le fera pas
pour les scientifiques
notre objectif c'est de limiter les
contacts de contact et uniquement ça
puisque pour ce qui est des personnes
que nous testons c'est déjà perdu
d'avancé
ils sont infectés et pour leurs contacts
il est déjà trop tard et c'est seulement
en accélérant le diagnostic que bernier
ton de limiter la propagation et les
français eux dans leur côté se doivent
absolument de s'isoler au moindre
symptôme et je vous rappelle que les
symptômes sont divers et variés nous
avons à la foire des céphalées à la fois
la perte la notion et la perte de la
paire de l'odorat et du goût mais nous
avons aussi dédiant simplement senlis
mans tous ces signes là doivent faire
français au comité va l'entraîner
isolement mais un autre tout il le vend
n'attendez pas d'avoir rendez vous chez
les femmes n'attendez pas de faire
peut-être n'attendez surtout pas d'avoir
des tests pour vous isoler alors c'est
un petit peu compliqué parce que c'est
vrai qu'on va pas tarder à rentrer dans
des périodes plus froides ya également
la grippe qui va s'inviter au milieu ça
paraît compliqué tout de même de
s'isoler de s'auto isolé quand on a un
gros rhume parce que en ce moment il ya
beaucoup de gens qui qui ont des rhumes
c'est pas nécessairement le coc vide
alors ça veut dire quoi qu'on dit à son
patron ben alors je vais pas venir
pendant huit jours parce que j'ai un
gros rhume ça peut être le co vide où on
se trompe de deux biais de discours je
vais très clair et très simple je
préfère mettre sept jours d'arrêt le
temps que ni le résultat du test à
quelqu'un que de m quatorze jours 30 ou
40 fois parce que quelqu'un est allé au
travail la responsabilité chacun dans le
nombre de personnes qu'ils vont infecter
était essentielle et donc le jeu de
j'entends bien il va falloir mettre
quelques arrêts et quand les symptômes
ont disparu
effectivement un green en grippe un brio
par âge ça disparaît en 3 quel jour on
sera fixé mais il faut nous laisser
mettre en arrêt de travail
les gens et il faut que les gens nous
aident à se mettre en arrêt de travail
parce que nous pouvons pas le faire
seuls alors on a aussi l'application
stop covin on en parle beaucoup elle
n'est pas franchement plébiscité il le
faudrait en ce moment c'est grave on a
parlé un petit peur on semble déjà la
petite ville qui piratent de compacts et
puis on voit bien que
la définition d'un calcul tac est
essentiellement à faire par le médecin
parce que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
qu'un simple prolongement de bluetooth
non je m'appelle réellement revenir à
quelque chose de simple et logique
le test a peut être prescrit par un
médecin parce qu'il a une utilité
on entend des votre confrère qui est
actuellement confiné qui attend un
résultat de test
en réalité il y avait même plus besoin
de le tester il suffisait de l'isoler au
niveau garder de toute façon ces
contacts de contacts sont déjà
contaminés ont déjà contaminé tout donc
ça sert plus à rien soit on teste dans
les deux premiers jours soit prendre des
jours 60 est plus aisé alors vous sortez
un livre en cette rentrée un journal
d'un médecin au temps du coronavirus
vous raconter votre expérience de
généraliste au plus fort de la crise
sanitaire vous expliquait d'ailleurs
avoir voulu alerter la presse régionale
sans avoir été pris vraiment au sérieux
vous vous le regrettez on a toujours un
temps de décalage et un tombe retards
réguliers vos confrères de la presse
régionale avait pris un peu de retard la
paix je le comprends quand on tirer des
larmes mais pas forcément tout le monde
a entendu et en même temps que je ne
l'aurais jamais fait de remerciement
pour vos confrères d'envoyés spéciaux
qui sont venus questionner et de
retourner pour regarder chez différents
et s'il vaut mieux totalement
merci beaucoup docteur le grand médecin
généraliste auteur d'un journal ou d'un
médecin au temps du courant navires us
aux éditions de l'archipel merci à vous
et les autorités académiques ont décidé
elle de fermer 21 une classe de
maternelle et de primaire du département
de seine saint denis dont un quart dans
la ville de montreuil
la raison le manque à l'appel de près de
4000 enfants décrochement un décrochage
scolaire ou peur du coc vie 19 personnes
sans pour le moment avoir une
explication à ces disparitions les
parents ont protesté contre la décision
des autorités craignant une dégradation
des conditions d'accueil mais aussi
d'enseignement certains parents d'élèves
disent aussi comprendre et côté c'est
vrai qu'en tant que maman on a un peu en
ans qu'on appréhende un peu on a un peu
peur jusqu'en se dit on sait pas comment
ça va se passer au niveau de la cantine
est ce qu ils sont collés avec les
autres au niveau de la cour de la récré
est ce qu'ils sont en train de jouer
ensemble ils se font des bisous en se
pose un peu des questions étant donné
que dans d'autres villes on n'entend
qu'eux il ya des enfants de leur âge qui
ont rattrapé de coronavirus alors en
tant que maire on a un peu peur oui bien
sûr on n'arrête pas d'en parler dans les
informations comme quoi que là il faut
faire attention que le corona est de
retour que le corona est de retour donc
c'est normal que les parents fassent
attention à leurs enfants et ne les
envoie pas à l'école après les enfants
entassés manqué de l'école pour y
retourner
il serait plus que temps et pour trois
aides avoir plus d'explications à nos
équipes ont rejoint l'académie de
créteil la réponse de la voyez en ce
moment sur votre écran l'académie qui
tient à rappeler que je cite ces
chiffres sont le résultat d'un constat
au premier jour de la rentrée qu'il
mérite donc naturellement d'être affinés
au fur et à mesure de l'arrivée aussi de
retardataires fin de citation alors 3900
élèves ça fait quand même beaucoup
déménagement hooper ducobu 19
le ministère cherche à comprendre en
affirmant que ce chiffre n'est qu'une
estimation peut-on parler de laxisme de
peur l'éducation nationale est elle
suffisamment bien géré la situation
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
kevin à bossuet un professeur d'histoire
dans un collège de seine-saint-denis
bonsoir kevin dossier merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés julie garnier porte
parole de la france insoumise bonsoir
julie garnier merci également à vous
d'avoir participé à ce face à face
alors tout d'abord la première réaction
vient entendre ses parents peu
déboussolé comment vous vous qualifiez 1
le professeur que vous êtes cette
rentrée kevin bossuet chaotique où
finalement plutôt bien organisé
non c'est une rentrée qui est plutôt
bien organisé on est dans un contexte un
peu particulier en effet où on doit
respecter certains gestes barrières qui
ne sont pas faciles à respecter
je pense par exemple au port du masque
il est vrai que pour des élèves de 6e
par exemple en collège il est très
difficile de conserver un masque que
toute la journée sur la figure mais
c'est également le cas évidemment des
enseignants qui doivent enseigner
enchaîné sept ou huit heures de cours
avec un mass notamment sur la bouche or
c'est pas facile
les rouges que quand même le ministère a
très bien géré cette crise puisque n'ya
le matériel nécessaire notamment au sein
de l'institution scolaire il ya du gel
hydroalcoolique les gestes barrières
sont respectés au maximum et je trouve
que c'est quand même très très bien fait
et voilà bravo à jean michel blanquer
pour cette rentrée qui est quand même
impeccable julie garnier je sens que
vous allez vous et on fait en tout cas
je vous vois faire des gros yeux vous ne
partagez pas l'avis de de kevin bossuet
sur cette rentrée plutôt bien organisé
selon lui il est professeur en guinée
sur le terrain ben moi aussi je suis sur
le terrain je suis parent d'élève et
aujourd'hui vous voyez j'étais dans une
occupation d'école primaire parce que ce
qu'on constate c'est qu'il n'ya pas
qu'eux en seine-saint-denis qui ferme
des classes mais c'est dans toute
l'académie de créteil c'est également en
seine-et-marne cédant val-de-marne et on
arrive à peu près à une centaine de
classes fermées ça c'est la réalité est
actuellement la réalité c'est que en
maternelle on a des classes qui vont se
retrouver à 31
je dis bien 31 en maternelle et ça c'est
ce qu'on a constaté aujourd'hui avec des
parents d'élèves qui est occupé l'école
donc non visiblement non on n'a pas du
tout la même réalité c'est que quand on
va sur le terrain on se rend bien compte
que malheureusement la rentrée ne se
passe absolument pas bien mais c'est
normal puisque nous avons un jean michel
lambert qui n'a absolument pas mis de
moyens supplémentaires
alors que on sort d'une période de post
confinement c'est à dire que les élèves
devaient avoir plus de soutiens devait
avoir plus d'accompagnement qu'on est
dans un protocole sanitaire qui a 31
dans une classe de maternelle avec un
seul robinet vous doutez bien que ça ne
sera jamais respecté et que des classes
tout simplement 1,30
c'est tout simplement insupportable et
inacceptable
donc ça vous voyez moi j'aime beaucoup
ce qu'ils disent que jean michel
blanquer a fait des bonnes choses et
préparer à tout mais quand on voit sur
le terrain c'est complètement différent
et aujourd'hui on voit que
malheureusement les primaires les
élémentaires les maternelles sont
vraiment les abandonner et les sacrifier
même je dirais de cette rentrée c'est
vrai que ça fait beaucoup toute cette
classe fermée kevin bossuet qu'est ce
que vous répondez non mais je crois que
j'ai en face de moi une interlocutrice
qui est complètement dans l'idéologie
qu'on va véritablement en termes
d'éducation aujourd'hui notion moi je
suis enseignant madame donc je vois ce
qui se passe concrètement sur le terrain
et je peux vous dire une chose c'est que
l'accompagnement personnalisé est mis en
place puisque pendant tout l'été jean
michel blanquer a mis en place les
vacances apprenantes qui ont permis
notamment à plein d'élèves d'origine
populaire de pouvoir bénéficier d'un
rattrapage scolaire et là le dispositif
devoirs faits et de l'aide aux devoirs
gratuits proposés notamment à tous les
enfants notamment d'origine modeste va
être renforcé la vérité c'est que jean
michel blanc terre est un ministre qui
lutte contre les inégalités sociales
il fait plus contre les inégalités
sociales que la gauche a pu le faire
notamment en dix ou quinze ans au
pouvoir donc voila moi je coupe et c'est
une très bonne rentrée les dispositifs
sont mis en place on ne rencontre pas de
gros problèmes sur le terrain
alors après évidemment je veux dire des
problèmes structurels au sein de
l'éducation nationale manque de
professeurs à certains franco etc mais
ce n'est pas à l'idée notamment à cette
rentrée spéciale bon voilà donc moi je
suis un professeur de terrain et je peux
vous dire que ça fonctionne et
heureusement parce que mes élèves parce
que les élèves de la république ont
beaucoup souffert de ce confinement et
j'aimerais dire bravo notamment à tous
ces enseignants qui ont fait tout ce
qu'il fallait pendant cette phase de
confinement pour faire en sorte que
l'enseignement à distance culte se
poursuivre alors justement on en vient à
ce chiffre est l'objet
débat près de 3900 élèves manquant à
l'appel en l'éducation nationale
relative à ce chiffre il dit que c'est
une estimation n'empêche que ça fait
voilà beaucoup de monde 1,5 fois plus
que d'habitude c'est clémentine autain
votre parti à la france d'un soumises
qui soulève le problème vous vous
l'expliquez comment julie garnier c'est
4000 près de 4000 élèves qui manquait à
l'appel en seine saint denis notamment
peur du virus déménagement des
décrochages après le confinement comment
quelle est votre analyse sur cette
question l'analyse elle serait déjà que
l'éducation nationale plutôt que de
s'amuser à fermer des écoles et à fermer
des classes elle ferait mieux justement
de s'inquiéter de ce phénomène là or on
voit que l'éducation nationale est
restée bloquée dans le monde d'avant et
que leur première logique face à ça
c'est pas de chercher le problème c'est
juste de fermer des classes donc au des
gens ont peu un petit peu quand même
s'étonner de leur pratique mais bien
évidemment quand on est manuelle macron
qui dit dans une interview que les
enseignants ne font pas partie du
redressement économique qui ne met aucun
moyen supplémentaire dans les écoles et
moi on se doute que finalement c'est pas
un problème pour eux et que moyennement
des bains du coup ça fait moins de profs
et ça fait moins de frais ils sont
restés dans une logique comptable et
c'est totalement préoccupant maintenant
j'aimerais juste rajouter ceci c'est que
avec des personnes qui gardent cette
logique comptable
on est en train de vraiment sacrifié nos
enfants et je déplore vraiment que
l'interlocuteur face à moi renie
totalement la réalité du terrain et que
quand on lui dit qu'il ya 137 cas ce qui
ferme en seine et marne qu'il ya 21 une
classe qui ferme en seine saint denis et
qu'il ya également des casques qui ferme
en ville demain c'est dire toute
l'académie de créteil
il ne s'étonne pas je suis vraiment
perplexe de ces gens qui sont là juste
pour faire de la communication politique
et qu'il nous parle changé légalement
bien donnez moi mais après mon frère est
jacky vimond bossuet mais est-ce que
c'est forcément la faute
voilà de l'éducation nationale parce
qu'on rappelle quand même
pardonnez moi mais que l'école est
obligatoire il ya d'ailleurs des des
amendes assez lourdes 1 pour ceux qui
n'en voient pas leurs enfants à l'école
est ce qui est une forme aussi peut-être
de laxisme du côté peut-être des
familles je me fais l'avocat du diable
il faut se poser la question
ce département a énormément élections
est effectivement de défections à la
rentrée scolaire c'est forcément la fois
de l'éducation nationale le premier
laxisme il est vraiment du côté
l'éducation nationale écoutez il faut
quand même et variées voire confus on va
comparer avec ce que ce qu'ont fait les
autres par exemple les autres pays
européens
faut savoir que l'espagne a pris comme
mesure à la rentrée de ne faire aucune
classe au dessus de 20 élèves pour
justement garantir un véritable
protocole sanitaire est un véritable
soutien
nous on avance et nous n'avons pas fait
ce choix jean michel blanquer radis non
mettront aucun moyen supplémentaire
quand vous avez vous avez d'autres choix
qui sont possibles vous aviez été moyens
qui étaient disponibles
or aujourd'hui on voit que ça va être
une hécatombe quand on a 28 écoles qui
sont fermés quand on a plus de 264 qui
sont fermés à cause justement du coc
vide
eh bien on peut que regretter
véritablement que jean-michel bancaire
n'ai pris aucune mesure aucun moyen
supplémentaire pour défendre nos enfants
et pour rassurer les familles ça c'est
un fait
et malheureusement que les gens aient
pris peur où que ce soit tout autre
raison il faut d'abord voir la première
défaillance est le premier des laxisme
et du côté de l'éducation nationale et
du gouvernement kevin boss fait vous
pensez que l'éducation nationale aurait
dû faire plus de pédagogie
peut-être rassurer ses parents inquiet
parce que c'est intéressant julie
garnier vous parliez d'espagne on va en
parler après c'est vrai que beaucoup de
parents ont aussi refusé de mettre leurs
enfants ont prévenu peut-être mais en
tout cas ils ont refusé
il ya ce laxisme du côté de l'éducation
nationale quand même kevin bossuyt on
aurait dû faire plus de pédagogie
oui mais on en sait déjà je veux dire
les parents les reçoit on leur explique
notamment le protocole sanitaire on leur
explique comment leurs enfants vont être
accueillis puis on leur explique ont pas
respecté les gestes barrières on va
donner de l'enseignement tout en
essayant de préserver la santé de tous
soit sale terry on peut voir une
représentante de la france insoumise me
dire que je fais de la communication
politique et je ne suis pas sur le
terrain
qu'est-ce que je suis enseignante je
suis professeur d'histoire géographie et
encore il ya quelques heures j'étais
dans ma salle de classe en train
notamment d'enseigner l'histoire
géographie donc ça fait plutôt rire et
moi ce qui me fait rire aussi ses
devoirs notamment cette dame donc avec
son éloquence naturel nous raconter que
si l'éducation nationale va mal c'est
parce qu'il ya un manque de moyens mais
en france on met beaucoup quand même
dans l'éducation nationale s'il part
budget inquiet quand même grandiloquent
et la vérité c'est que c'est l'idée
logis de madame garnier qui responsable
du délitement de l'éducation nationale
c'est toute l'idéologie soixante huitard
que cette militante de la france un sou
ni sport qui a fait en sorte que
l'autorité du maître et sans arrêt
remise en cause et même que l'autorité
de l'école est remise en cause
et quand je vois notamment les militants
de la france insoumise ce plat notamment
qu'il ya beaucoup de parents en seine
saint denis qui ont décroché avec
l'école alors que ces gens là ne cesse
d'être dans la mouvance islamo gauchiste
et de surfer notamment pour toute cette
mouvance indigéniste qui justement
décrochent les enfants de la république
de nichols de mode il ya elle se fiche
quand même pas mal du monde au moins
qu'elle ne me reproche pas de ne pas
être sur le terrain alors que j'y suis
tous les jours je les gardais votre a
répondu oui
moi ce que je regrette c'est que ce
monsieur dit beaucoup de mots mais ne
donne pas beaucoup de chiffres il dit
que la france met beaucoup de moyens
mais je rappellerai juste que la france
est en dessous de la moyenne de l'oscd
eux concernant les dépenses publiques
par élève ça c'est un fait on voyait
bien que le nom la france ne met pas du
tout les moyens qu'elle devrait mettre
ensuite les enseignants sont aussi en
dessous de la moyenne de l'oecd eux pour
leur salaire ils sont exactement entre
la pologne et la hongrie
tous que la moyenne de l'oscd le juste
pour encore donner un outil l'ifra
monsieur pour qu'ils se rendent bien
compte quand même de la précarité de
l'éducation nationale c'est que la
moyenne de l'oscd en primaire ses 21
élèves nous en france on est en moyenne
de 25
et encore on sent monter jusqu'à 30 31
comme je les dis quand j'ai cité cet
exemple de classe en seine et marne qui
se retrouvent à 31 élèves en moyenne
section exactement donc voilà où le
problème des ce monsieur c'est qu'il dit
beaucoup de phrases qui n'ont aucun sens
avec des mots dont il connaît pas très
bien les définitions également mais les
chiffres il les connaît pas et les
chiffres n'ont justement les sites et
ils vont dans le sens où non l'éducation
nationale n'a pas les moyens qu'à mérite
en tout cas un manuel macron s'est
adressé à la jeunesse cet après-midi sur
les réseaux sociaux il a fait passer un
message le président écoute et il n'y
aura pas de génération sacrifiée
c'était rapide
kevin bossuet justement la génération
sacrifiée
ce confinement c'était en tout cas l'un
des soucis affichée par le ministre
l'éducation jean michel blanquer à ce
que ce confinement selon vous entraîner
le sacrifice d'une génération entière et
notamment sur le plan économique un ca
serait justement l'illustration avec ses
4000 élèves qui qui manquait à la
rentrée ou peut-être c'est un peu
prématuré de dire ça oui bien sûr
évidemment c'est les élèves les plus en
difficulté qui ont souffert notamment de
ce confinement puisque l'enseignement à
distance qui étaient mises en place
notamment au cours du confinement a
porté ses fruits pour les élèves
notamment qui est équipée où les élèves
qui avaient des parents derrière eux
pour les aider mais c'est vrai qu'à lice
cet enseignement est laissé sur le côté
notamment des élèves qui n'avaient pas
forcément la connexion internet adéquat
l'outil informatique adéquat qui avaient
des parents qui n'étaient pas là pour
les aider non et heureusement que les
professeurs de terrain était là qui est
professeur de terrain qui sont loin de
l'idéologie de madame garnier parce que
pendant que nous on était super terrain
les syndicats qui se revendiquent de
l'idéologie de madame dernier faisait
tout pour essayer de trouver des
justificatifs pour rester en télétravail
parce que apparemment il a bitter peur
du vide alors que leur but était
évidemment d'en faire le moins possible
et moi j'aimerais quand même aussi citer
des études parce que moi je suis quand
même sur le terrain j'ai pas besoin des
chiffres pour m'accueillir pour
maquiller notamment montré mon inculture
en termes d'éducation nationale je
prends juste le classement pisa qui est
quand même le classement de référence
qui pointent notamment que l'un des
problèmes dans l'éducation nationale en
france et notamment le taux d'un
discipline dans les classes c'est à dire
c'est parce que à certains endroits sur
certains territoires de la république
en fait on n'arrive plus à faire cours
normalement parce qu'il ya un tel degré
d'un discipline que finalement
l'instruction devient impossible et ça
c'est encore la conséquence que de
l'idéologique porte madame garnier donc
elle a beau faire de faire drôle
insultes comme à l'habitude vous êtes
invectives et je vous propose deux voilà
la politesse et de vous laisser le mot
de la fin mai ce couple est très
rapidement ce qu'on devrait déjà avoir
terminé donc peut-être une petite phrase
s'il vous plaît en réponse juste en
réponse fin en même temps quand on a que
l'insulté il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'arguments derrière juste heureux même
rappelé les chiffres c'est que
malheureusement quand on a des classes
surchargées
quand on n'a pas les moyens et que avec
les enseignants qui ont fait ce qu'ils
pouvaient justement pour poursuivre et
d'ailleurs je rappellerai juste qu'il ya
quand même des enseignants qui sont mort
du co vite donc il y ait au moins un peu
de respect pour ces morts-là 6
play je crois que oui malheureusement on
est dans une génération sacrifiée mais
comme tous les services publics avec
monsieur macron c'est toujours avec
l'hôpital avec l'école avec la justice
etc et services publics qui sont servis
en dernier
et malheureusement c'est la république
et les jeunes qui en souffrent les
premiers merci en tout cas on aura
compris que la seule solution de la
france insoumis c'est l'augmentation des
impôts c'est à dire le mépris que cette
femme si vous voulez avec plaisir en
tout cas vous avez le jouer tous les
deux le jeu du débat merci à vous deux
kevin bossuet julie garnier d'avoir été
avec nous et d'accepter donc ce face à
face en direct sur rt france il est
quasiment 20 ans
soyez les bienvenus si vous nous
rejoignez 21h30 heure française la
rentrée scolaire fait des morts en
espagne aussi en a pas qu'en france de
plus en plus de parents d'élèves
refusent de mettre précisément leurs
enfants à l'école en cause des mesures
sanitaires insuffisant selon eux
aurélie chamerois avec grégoire douce et
une rentrée en ordre dispersé si dans
certaines régions espagnoles les enfants
ont déjà repris le chemin de l'école
la situation est différente dans le
reste du pays comme à barcelone où cette
rentrée est prévue lundi prochain et où
les mesures sanitaires mises en place
pour l'occasion ne font pas l'unanimité
loin de là depuis quelques semaines une
association catalane de parents
militants pour une école plus sur ses
formes et elle rassemble près de 4000
familles qui envisage de faire la grève
de l'école
si le protocole sanitaire n'est pas
renforcée celui ci prévoit à l'heure
actuelle le port du masque obligatoire
pour tous et par tous à partir de 6 ans
des désinfections et ventilation
régulière et des mises en quarantaine
dans les classes touchées par des
contaminations parmi les réclamations de
ces familles un ratio d'élèves par
classe beaucoup plus bas davantage de
professeurs et de personnel de nettoyage
mais aussi des soignants disponibles
dans les établissements
parallèlement elles veulent avoir le
choix de mettre ou non leur enfant à
l'école
c'est sa came anne mère de deux enfants
s'apprête à faire la grève de l'école
dès lundi prochain il permis à la
famille les hp d'acquérir un système
audio line nous voulons que les familles
puissent choisir entre un système à 10
présentiel ou semi présentiel comme cela
pour les familles qui ont des personnes
à risque ou des élèves qui ont des
nécessités éducatif comme les autistes
par exemple et qui pourrait être
affectée par une situation nouvelle
nous pensons que cela serait approprié
de pouvoir choisir l'éducation à la
maison qui les protègerait de toutes ces
situations
chez certains experts le son de cloche
est différent si l'espagne est en pleine
deuxième vague la situation est sous
contrôle et les parents devraient plutôt
s'attacher à respecter les gestes
barrières pour le groupe de chercheurs
catalans sur locaux vides 19
le pire est passé et les enfants peuvent
retourner en classe sans inquiétude
particulière il est évident que nous
n'allons pas revenir à la situation de
mars avril en espagne une situation les
hôpitaux était complètement saturée et
la mortalité était très élevé à kenge
plainte hamamouche il faut maintenant
nous savons à quoi nous faisons face en
mars nous ne savions pas réellement donc
notre capacité d'action est très
supérieur par rapport à celle que nous
avions à ce moment là si le taux
d'incidence augmente beaucoup nous
savons que nous avons la possibilité du
confinement
ce qui est important c'est que les
politiques soient courageux et ferme les
villes les routes et que si c'est
nécessaire les gens restent chez eux une
chose cacher le gouvernement espagnol
lui a fait le choix de la fermeté toute
famille qui ne mettra pas ses enfants à
l'école s'exposera à des poursuites
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
philippe emmanueli médecins français
exerçant en espagne bonsoir docteur
emmanuel y merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france abordé par an qui
ont déjà annoncé qu'ils ne remettraient
pas leurs enfants à l'école malgré les
menaces de sanction du gouvernement à ce
que vaut tant que médecin vous comprenez
ses choix si oui j'ai discuté
aujourd'hui avec deux mères de famille
qui était confronté
objectivement à cette situation est ce
qu'elle me disait c'est que elle
souhaite avant tout qu'il y ait de la
cohérence est ce que reproche
aujourd'hui un petit peu les parents
d'élèves
c'est parfois les messages
contradictoires et le manque de
cohérence parfois dans les mesures qui
sont prises par exemple une mère de
famille me citer l'exemple d'un grand
lycée à barcelone où les classes étaient
bien divisés en groupe avec pour chaque
groupe des bracelets de couleur
différente
et puis tout d'un coup à la sortie du
lycée des milliers d'élèves qui se
retrouvaient agrégé ensemble à la sortie
de l'école sans aucune distanciation et
donc avec effectivement eu un point
d'interrogation sur la cohérence des
mesures qui sont prises
effectivement au niveau des
établissements on nous a pourtant rabat
cher son nom justement des médecins vos
confrères d'equidia c'est même une
tribune dans un quotidien de médecins
que les enfants n'étaient pas vecteur de
ce virus est ce que cette posture est
toujours d'actualité
c'est vrai qu'on n'a encore toujours
beaucoup d'incertitudes c'est à dire que
effectivement on voit bien aujourd'hui
qu'on assiste à une vague de
contamination importante avec un taux de
mortalité inférieur mais personne n'est
capable aujourd'hui d'expliquer pourquoi
on a cette nouvelle configuration
épidémiologique et probablement comme
dans toute épidémie on a faim on est
face à un phénomène vivant et
probablement les choses évoluent et
peut-être qu'à un moment les enfants
peuvent ne pas être vecteurs de
l'épidémie est un autre moment dans
d'autres circonstances parce que
l'environnement change devenir d'avec
devenir un vecteur d'épidémie donc c'est
très difficile d'avoir des positions
extrêmement tranché scientifiquement au
stade où on en est deux
la connaissance de l'épidémie ça veut
dire qu'on est finalement un prénom que
ça soit en france ou en espagne selon
vous de rouvrir les écoles quel est le
point de vue du du médecin comment
aurait-on pu faire autrement
non sans doute pas il faut continuer à
vivre il faut avancer et il faut avancer
avec les connaissances tel quel
telle qu'elle se dire telle qu elle se
perfectionne effectivement avec le temps
et avec les données donc non cette
rentrée était nécessaire simplement
effectivement ce qui est perturbant pour
la population c'est de ne pas pouvoir
avoir je dirais un discours qui soit
scientifiquement parfaitement clair mais
c'est en raison effectivement du manque
de connaissances qu'on a aujourd'hui des
tenants et des aboutissants de cette
épidémie
la situation préoccupe également les
évidemment les enseignants qui ont déjà
annoncé qu'ils feront grève tente neuf
mille professeurs sont recherchés pour
permettre de reprendre les cours dans de
bonnes conditions notamment en catalogne
et en galice
ce que ça vous semble atteignable comme
objectif vous comprenez en tout cas
c'est ses professeurs oui c'est vrai que
les professeurs ils sont en première
ligne dans cette affaire il se retrouve
effectivement dans des dans des
environnements et des configurations
qu'on peut qualifier quand même malgré
toi risque puisqu'ils sont en
collectivité et c'est vrai que moi je
peux comprendre qu'il y ait une part de
craintes pour autant
nous sommes face aujourd'hui
effectivement à une épidémie inné de
l'it et il faut tous ensemble avancer en
essayant effectivement de d'appliquer
les mesures qui nous sont dictées pour
faire face à cette épidémie
aujourd'hui clairement tant que médecin
en espagne vous parleriez clairement de
deuxième vague on sait une première
vague qui ne s'est jamais arrêté vous
êtes inquiet alors c'est pas moi qui en
parlent mais aujourd'hui un des grands
hôpitaux universitaires de barcelone
l'hôpital german trias a publié une
étude sur les perspectives de l'épidémie
en espagne en europe et eux-mêmes
parlent des buts deuxième vague il parle
même il utilise même cette expression de
canari dans la mine de charbon
vous savez que autrefois dans les mines
de charbon les mineurs avaient un canari
pour j'ai à dire est détecté la présence
le risque d'un coup de grisou parce que
le canari mourey est aujourd'hui les
chercheurs disent mais les canaris c'est
l'espagne nous sommes le canari de
l'europe
et si effectivement les choses
s'aggravent ici eh bien on pourra dire
qu'une seconde vague a déferlé sur toute
l'europe
effectivement l'espagne le pays le plus
touché d'europe après avoir dépassé les
500 mille cas comment vous expliquer
justement cette entre guillemets
spécificité espagnol alors là aussi les
chercheurs ont publié une étude il ya
deux ou trois jours et eu effectivement
ont symbolisé ça en appelant sa le
trident de l'espagne avec trois dents
qui explique 7,7 effectivement cette
caractéristique espagnol la première
dent et bien c'est le mode de
convivialité les bars les restaurants la
deuxième danse et
effectivement la faiblesse du réseau de
dépistage et la troisième dans c'est
effectivement le relâchement dans la
mobilité qui a eu lieu plus tôt en
espagne que dans d'autres pays européens
entre les différentes communautés
espagnoles
merci à philippe emmanuel y médecins
français exerçant en espagne d'avoir été
avec nous à moins de deux mois de
l'élection présidentielle américaine
tous les coups sont permis dans notre et
joe biden multiplie les sorties et les
critiques alors que ces dernières
semaines le mouvement black
liles matters était au centre de
l'actualité les deux candidats ont
réajusté leurs discours priorité
désormais au coronavirus walid ben ali
plus que de simples déclarations
donald trump et joe biden se livrent une
véritable guerre des mots objectifs et
décrédibiliser l'adversaire sur un sujet
des plus sensibles
le coc vide 19 le président américain
lui a une idée fixe la prochaine
découverte d'un vaccin d'ici au vote
puis 3 novembre qui pourrait tout
changer
by donné sa colistière très libérale la
personne la plus libérale au congrès et
d'ailleurs n'est pas une personne
compétente à mon avis ils détruiraient
ce pays et ils détruiraient cette
économie il devrait immédiatement
s'excuser pour la rhétorique anti
vaccins imprudente dont il parle en ce
moment qui parle de mettre des vies en
danger et qui sape la science mais le
vaccin sera très sûr et très efficace il
sera livré très bientôt et vous pourriez
avoir une très grosse surprise
je suis sûr que vous serez très heureux
mais les gens seront heureux les gens du
monde seront heureux
une conférence de presse surprise en
réponse aux propos tenus quelques heures
plus tôt par kamala harris
la colistière du candidat démocrate joe
biden je prie pour que nous disposions
le plus rapidement possible d'un vaccin
approuvé par les scientifiques et les
professionnels de la santé publique
feriez-vous confiance à l'un d'entre eux
sous la direction du président entre
hommes jean croirait ainsi les
professionnels de la santé publique et
les scientifiques nous disait que nous
pouvons lui faire confiance
cette défiance donald trump la fustige
alors que les etats-unis sont le pays le
plus touché par la pandémie de kovy 19
avec plus de 6 millions 300 mille cas et
bientôt 190 mille décès parallèlement le
président américain est critiquée après
que l'agencé américaine du médicament a
déclaré pouvoir délivrer une
autorisation d'urgence à un futur vaccin
avant même la fin des essais cliniques
censé confirmer sa fiabilité
une décision qui sera scientifique a
toutefois tempéré l'autorité américaine
du met
dicaments cette dernière avait
d'ailleurs autorisé fin mars et lead
roxy chloroquine vanté par donald trump
avant de se raviser en juin un double
discours
taclé par joe biden qui multiplie les
déplacements dans des états clés l'un
des problèmes avec sa façon de jouer
avec la politique et qu'il dit tellement
de choses qui ne sont pas vrai que je
crains que même si nous avons un vrai
bon vaccin des personnes hésiteront à
aller se faire vacciner
ils savent donc la confiance du public
mais prions dieu que nous en ayons un si
je pouvais avoir un bon vaccin demain je
le ferai si cela me coûtait l'élection
je le ferai nous avons besoin d'un
vaccin et nous en avons besoin
maintenant le plus vite possible
les etats unis ont investi plus de 10
milliards de dollars dans la recherche
d'un vaccin
un vaccin miracle mais aussi
providentiel et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis washington avec
olivier py ton avocat sur place
observateurs de la vie politique
américaine
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir olivier python merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
alors même si donald trump sont défend
avec la crise sanitaire le vaccin le
fameux semble être devenu un véritable
argument de campagne
oui en fait on a l'impression que vous
n'en sort pas c'est à dire que tout
devient politique est clivant on avait
déjà eu ça avec les différenciations
sociales et gestes barrières les masques
on a maintenant cela avec le vaccin faut
bien comprendre l'enjeu c'est à dire que
donald trump joue une partie de sa
remontée dans les sondages qu'elle tente
de remonter dans les sondages en
promettant la vaccin dans les semaines
ou les mois qui viennent en tout cas
avant l'élection du 3 novembre et les
démocrates évidemment sentant le danger
laisse entendre que le seul vaccin
estampillé par les scientifiques sur
quoi ils ont évidemment raison serait
valable donc on est de nouveau dans une
politisation d'un d'un fait santé il ya
qu aux etats-unis que c'est le cas où
est peut-être au brésil où on a
effectivement une politisation il ya un
clivage systématique pour ce qui
concerne la pandémie de cornavin est-ce
que donald trump tout de même trouve des
soutiens justement dans cette promesse
de lancer avec ça avant la
présidentielle donc avant le 3 novembre
pas tant que ça aujourd'hui new york
times a fait une article sur le fait que
17 laboratoires américains s'engager à
ne pas produire deux vaccins sont qu'ils
aient été ces vaccins dûment contrôlées
et recontrôler donc en fait c'est un
petit peu un cavalier seul de la part de
donald trump qui joue aussi son va-tout
parce qu'il est même si l'écart se
resserre il est quand même en retard par
rapport à dubaï donne et il a besoin un
petit peu comme le dit très bien votre
votre reportage de marquer un coup mais
il est un peu seul pour le marquer pour
l'instant c'est un pari qu'il fait dans
l'avenir pour l'avenir alors en tout cas
donald trump lui dénonce la rhétorique
anti vaccins ils responsables de joe
biden comment il perçu le discours du
candidat démocrate
outre atlantique si on vous suit bien il
est plutôt soutenu oui évidemment
soutenu il faut bien comprendre qu'on
est pratiquement affront envers ses sept
aujourd'hui
donald trump qui parle de
l'irresponsabilité sanitaire de jubail
donne alors que pendant des mois c'était
plutôt les démocrates qui parlait de
l'irresponsabilité en matière de
politique sanitaire de donald trump
on est si vous voulez dans un moment de
grande tension du fait que l'élément
vaccin peut convaincre une partie de
l'électorat américain soit de continuer
à soutenir dubai donne soit de se
tourner vers donald trump donc l'enjeu
est extrêmement important il y en a
d'autres
la loi et l'ordre sur les problèmes de
2,2 d'émeutes également donc c'est un
moment un petit peu charnière on est on
est à quelques jours on est à trois
semaines du premier débat qui aura lieu
le 29 septembre et qui va sans doute
rebattre encore l'écart donc il faut se
positionner et pour l'instant le
positionnement comme je le dis il est
plutôt à contre contre-courant c'est à
dire que le défenseur de l'est sécurité
sanitaire de liens donald trump au
détriment de joe biden est ce que les
électeurs vont se laisser prendre c'est
moins sûr
mais en tout cas c'est intéressant ça
veut dire si on vous écoute bien ça peut
devenir un enjeu vous avez dit cette
histoire de vaccin ça veut dire qu'on va
finalement arriver un débat pro et anti
vaccin sur fond de débat scientifique
c'est cela que va devenir cette
présidentielle américaine
c'est un peu ça va devenir effectivement
cette présidentielle américaine il faut
bien comprendre que dans une situation
je crois vraiment des états unis où tous
les repères sanitaires sont extrêmement
difficiles à à connecter ou d'abord le
pays est extrêmement touché le koala
virus est le pays le plus touché 185
mille morts 25 milles entre 25000
quarante mille nouveaux cas tous les
jours
donc c'est un pays qui est profondément
traumatisée et qu' aujourd'hui n'a plus
véritablement
dans la parole politique d'ailleurs
qu'elle soit républicaines ou démocrates
et donc chaque chaque chiot surenchère
d'une certaine manière ne facilite pas
la compréhension par le public et donc
par les lecteurs de ce qu'il doit faire
ou de ce qu'il doit penser de la
politique sanitaire aux états unis et au
delà des élections présidentielles qui
est extrêmement grave dans cette
histoire c'est qu'on contribue à
délégitimer la parole politique dans le
domaine sanitaire et donc dans le
domaine politique d'une manière beaucoup
plus large et ça c'est extrêmement
inquiétant et pour envoyer un petit peu
les acteurs dont ado tout le monde y
participe de manière un peu égal et on
ne sait pas comment tout cela va sortir
et là je parle d'après le 3 novembre
on sait qu'il ya d'autres problèmes aux
états unis ont les commente aussi depuis
la france notamment les violences
policières sis à donald trump perdait
cette présidentielle est ce qu'on pourra
dire qu'il se sera fracasser sur cette
crise sanitaire liée aux coronavirus
puisqu'on rappelle que les choses se
passaient pas si mal pour lui
avant cette crise incontestablement la
pandémie on lui aura été fatal s'il perd
le 3 novembre
on se souvient des sondages du mois de
février où il était largement donné
vainqueur quel que soit le candidat
démocrate en face et la plongée a
commencé à partir des mois de mars et
d'avril donc évidemment sa gestion de la
pandémie ou sa non gestion de la
pandémie selon le point de vue dans le
calme ils se placent à contribuer ou va
contribuer à la situation actuelle est
peut-être à sa défaite
effectivement c'est la pandémie qui sera
responsable de la défaite éventuelle
donald trump le 3 novembre c'est
incontestable
merci beaucoup olivier py tour avocat
washington observateurs de la vie
politique américaine de nous avoir
apporté votre point de vue vu de
l'extérieur et on en vient aux dossiers
nord stream ii au coeur du débat dans le
sillage des accusations d'empoisonnement
dans la sphère navalni la france et les
etats unis ont émis des réserves quant à
la construction du gazoduc censé relier
la russie à l'allemagne
berlin a également déclaré ne plus
exclure l'éventualité de retirer son
soutien au projet toutes les précisions
avec notre correspondant à moscou
antoine claireaux
un gala merkel l'a annoncé l'avenir de
nord stream 2 et bien sûr la table et ce
ne sera pas une décision allemande mais
bien d'une décision européenne pendant
longtemps l'allemagne faisait pourtant
la part des choses entre d'un côté la
diplomatie et de l'autre ses propres
intérêts économiques mais cela ne semble
plus être le cas tout du moins dans ce
dossier la france par la voix de son
secrétaire d'état chargée aux affaires
européennes a pour sa part réitéré ses
réserves concernant la poursuite du
chantier du gazoduc nord stream ii il ya
aussi eu la réaction des états unis
donald trump dans la nuit a sans
surprise rappelé qu'il soutiendrait la
suspension du chantier
eh bien je soutiens ça j'ai été le
premier à en parler vous n'avez jamais
entendu parler de nord stream 2 avant
l'arrivée de trump quand je suis arrivé
j'ai dit attendez une minute en protège
l'allemagne de la russie n'est ce pas
d'ailleurs si le chantier n'est pas
encore terminée à l'heure actuelle c'est
en grande partie à cause des sanctions
américaines qui ont à plusieurs reprises
interrompu l'avancée des travaux et en
réponse à toutes ces déclarations le
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
a tenu à clarifier sa position sur ce
dossier
nous entendons toutes ses déclarations
mais notre position est bien connu il
s'agit d'un projet commercial qui doit
rester en dehors de la politique car il
contribue à renforcer la sécurité
énergétique de l'europe elle-même et à
créer une plateforme pour le
développement de la coopération
économique et bien évidemment nous
partons du principe que ces intérêts
doivent prévaloir
quant aux déclarations des responsables
américains il n'y a rien de nouveau
il lutte de façon cohérente et
systématique contre north stream
mais nous estimons que l'europe doit en
fin de compte trouver la force de faire
connaître ses intérêts nationaux
si elle ne veut pas se retrouver dans
une situation de vassal
d'autant que si berlin abandonne le
projet il devra payer de lourdes
compensations aux entreprises impliquées
et depuis qu'elle a arrêté le nucléaire
en 2011
l'allemagne a besoin du gaz russe à bon
marché pour soutenir sa transition
énergétique renoncer à leur stream
devrait donc d'importantes conséquences
pour berlin autant sur le plan
économique que sur le plan politique à
long terme
et ce soir le g7 exhorté moscou à
traduire en justice
urgent amant les auteurs du présumé
empoisonnement plus tôt dans la soirée
la france a décidé de reporter une
réunion ministérielle franco-russe
initialement prévue le 14 septembre
retour à présent sur les nombreux
rebondissements de cette affaire l'ex
qu'il n'avait ni en images
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans
quelques minutes à 22 heures pour un
point complet sur l'actualité de la
journée pourriez aisément yes dn on se
retrouve demain 20 heures
merci à
[Musique]
en pleine crise du courant d'un virus
après avoir constaté l'incapacité de
l'union européenne à manifester la
moindre solidarité envers des etam
l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise la montée
en puissance de la chine dans le
commerce mondial a évidemment réduit le
poids de l'euro il faut y ajouter la
fragmentation de la zone et son
incapacité à parler d'une seule voix la
rend beaucoup moins attractif il est
évident que le projet politique d'une
véritable union est mort entre des
membres trop différente et trop non la
vraie question est de savoir si le
président français va vouloir et pouvoir
rebondir et comment les choix sont
multiples mais tout le problème va être
bien choisi
[Musique]
entre 800 et 1000 tonnes de fuel se sont
déversés dans les eaux turquoises
mauricienne ce qu'il faudrait étendre l
enquête aux autorités portuaires voir
plus haut
nous devons annoncer une enquête d'une
voie en maintenant établir la chaîne de
responsabilités nationales
il faut savoir que la partie arrière du
bateau contient encore environ 50 à 100
tonnes de fioul
donc ça pourrait aussi actuellement se
fracasser et causé un deuxième
déversement de pétrole plus ça arrive
après les convives 19 avons secteur
hôtelier et touristique du tarn où des
impacts de la catastrophe sur
l'environnement marin mais aussi sur les
populations niveau de la santé vont se
faire ressentir pendant des décennies il
faut s'attendre aujourd'hui à maurice
aussi un désastre sanitaire
il est catastrophe on a vécu voilà
pourquoi je suis pas si pessimiste que
c'est
nous voulons transmettre aux enfants les
souvenir encore vif
ce qui nous est arrivé nous qui étions
de jeunes prisonniers lors de la grande
guerre patriotique
la seconde guerre mondiale il tragédie
pour toute l'humanité
des chars la dévastation un obus des
explosions nous étions enfants ils
n'avions pas faire des morts
nous avions peur des allemands c'est dur
de revivre ça des millions de victimes
de vie anéantie
la fin car ce que percée des tirs les
enfants qui pleurent rient les mères qui
pleurent mais bon je me souviens qu'un
jour alors que je marchais j'ai vu en
vieil homme allongé il était
probablement déjà mort déjà rigide un
petit garçon lui ramper dessus essayant
de le réveiller
jamais dans l'histoire la cruauté envers
les enfants n'avaient atteint cette
ampleur survivre et aura compté bien
nous avons survécu 18 millions de
personnes sont passées par 14000 camps
de concentration ghetto et prison 2 5
millions d'enfants sont morts